hey what's going on this is bill burr
and it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
and i'm just checking in on you
sorry
um
what's going on how's your week going is
it going good
that weird
you know depressing time between
christmas
and new year's but then the excitement
of like oh man i'm gonna make it through
the holidays
without killing myself
um
yeah it's a uh
it's always a weird week you know i used
to like it when i was a kid
there's always a bummer man when
christmas was over is there anything
more exciting than a christmas tree with
the presents around it
and equally as depressing is
afterwards you know
the tree stops getting watered it's just
sitting there
like an old pop star
just doing the casinos now
singing its old hits have a holly jolly
christmas thank you
it's the best time of the year you
remember god hey you know sticking the
mic out for the [ __ ] high parts
oh ho come on he'll be out the mistletoe
um
anyway but i decided that this week i
was gonna uh i was gonna try to sleep
something i barely i don't do enough and
i'm reading all of this stuff
online so god knows if it's [ __ ]
correct
i mean you really just have to take
everything
that you read online like this has to be
like everybody is just spinning it
everybody is just spinning it it's just
all
filthy [ __ ]
closers coming in like a 1970s closer
mustard on your shirt vaseline on the
bill of your hat every [ __ ] [ __ ] out
there
it's just spinning
just [ __ ] the bulls just the
[ __ ] of them
you know
the whole [ __ ] you go to somebody's
uh
i don't know those stupid [ __ ] yeah
what do you call them
their page their site
their their asset
i don't know
just looking at it it's going like it's
like
this looks like an ad
you know
for a hotel or something and it's like
somebody's life
it's like pictures of like
the perfect breakfast
then there's linens working out
sunsets
uh all right whatever
stop judging bill i i make a living
doing it i've painted myself into a
corner i have to do it um
speaking
oh before i get into that i'm getting
judged and everything before i get into
that [ __ ] let's talk um
me and my lovely wife
um watch this documentary on kenny g
that i highly
highly highly recommend
that i highly recommend it was
absolutely uh i loved every second of it
it was fascinating
and um
you know i've met him a couple times
he's a great [ __ ] guy and a great
pilot
and um he actually was the guy that told
me who to call
i think i ran into him i swear to god at
the hollywood bowl
i was going in to go see vinnie
carliutta play with herbie hancock
there's no [ __ ] way i was missing
that right
and uh
i forget somebody that knew me knew him
and was with him
and he's like you want to meet kenny g i
was like [ __ ] yeah i want to meet kenny
g
guys sold like 100 million records
absolutely
so i went over and they hey this bill
because he's like i know you i've seen
your thing i'm blind so i know you too
you
i go you're a scratch golfer cause
that's what i heard about him whatever
and he just was the coolest [ __ ] guy
so i said hey you know i fly too
cause a buddy of mine had run into him
one night
um
years and years ago
and some bar was like hey are you kenny
g he said yeah he goes what are you
doing here did you play have a gig
tonight he said nah you know i'm flying
just the weather wasn't good it was
night so i just landed here and just
stay in here for the night or whatever
so i remembered that he was a pilot but
anyway he was the one that introduced me
to randy my instructor
uh that helped me with my instrument
rating even though
it didn't work out it hasn't worked out
yet i got to retake the test i just got
too [ __ ] busy um
but anyway
i you got to see this documentary i mean
you want to talk about somebody
you know i'll give you one little
snippet of it the guy goes on the
tonight show
the record label wants him to play a
song he doesn't want to play
he wants to play that song songbird
that he wrote he wants to play his music
so i don't know johnny goes long
and then i don't know what happened i
forget basically they say you only have
time for one song so he says [ __ ] we're
playing this song
and the band's like i don't know man the
label's gonna get pissed he's like
basically
don't screw me over i'm playing this
song just do it so he starts playing the
song
and while he's on the tonight show oh
sorry the lovely nia everybody i don't
know
i know i know i usually do it in the
garage but i'm i'm here
i'm in the middle of telling just one
little snip how great was the kenny g
documentary it's so good
yeah so the guys on the tonight show
which you got you gotta understand this
guy used to get like a 30 share
like essentially a third of the friggin
houses in america were watching it so if
you bombed
you were finished what's up buddy you
going to bed
huh
can't say bye-bye
say bye-bye
shaking your head no can you say bye-bye
you say
so cool
he's just waving can you say dada
all right
okay bye-bye all right love you buddy
bye buddy i'll see you in the morning
okay it's hilarious
um
so kenny says [ __ ] it i'm playing my
song so he starts playing the song the
crowd's listening and i guess the guy
that you know was booked into tonight's
show was didn't want kenny to play it he
was pissed
and he was making all these hand
gestures for him to stop playing it or
whatever allegedly maybe even like on
the sly giving him the finger
or whatever and the fact that he could
plow through that
and still just play his song and then
the big thing is then it turns out to be
this huge hit so a lot of the
documentary
um
was really inspiring because you know as
you people know
if you go to do anything
put a little edition on your house the
[ __ ] boo birds come out
really
you know is it gonna be up to code
you're gonna get a permit
i don't know man i heard them things
leak you know just people just start
[ __ ] on you and [ __ ] on you and
[ __ ] on you and this guy
just [ __ ]
plows through all of it
and gets to where he's at it's just it's
a [ __ ] phenomenal
it's just a phenomenal documentary at um
how people react to other people's
success how to handle success
how ridiculously obsessed people can
become with somebody good or bad you
know in a good way or a bad way i mean
it was just was [ __ ] fascinating
you got to check it out you got to check
it out so uh
i don't even know where we watched it
and he has of course found that one
she's like you want to watch this [ __ ]
i'm like absolutely so anyway
um
i'm going to be in phoenix
arizona
um thursday today
i'm gonna be out there
and now what i usually i i've only done
it one time every time i go to arizona i
go you know i'm gonna do that camelback
mountain hike
i only did it one time a long time ago
and um
it was a bad it was a big mistake
big [ __ ] mistake i was not in the
shape i needed to be and i had to do two
shows that night at the improv
the old tempi improvement jesus christ
it wasn't even the ascent it was coming
back
with my legs i felt like you know
reminding me way back in the day when i
actually went skiing i used to go skiing
and that you remember you know when you
always think you got one more run in you
and you don't realize that your legs are
spaghetti and you get off the chairlift
and basically fall back down the
mountain
at least i did
it was like one of those things
so um
but anyway i had a great uh
great couple of days off and i actually
went
flying
the other day
and
there's nothing better than flying la
the day after it rains
it is absolutely gorgeous and i am
convinced that those are the days
when people go up in helicopters and
they take pictures for postcards to try
to get tourists to come out here
because that's the day when you can see
like downtown l.a with the snow covered
mountain in the background it's [ __ ]
amazing so
me and a buddy of mine went flying and i
was like let's go uh
let's go on the back side of the san
gabriels that sound like um
you know i wanted to fly out towards
victorville like the beginning of the
mojave desert and everything and we flew
out that way
and
you know
there was all of these clouds literally
touching the top
of the san gabriel mountains in certain
areas
you know so we obviously stayed away
from that because we can't fly into the
clouds but then there's also you know
showing that there's a lifting force the
big cumulus clouds and all that so we
thought it was going to be a little
bumpy but
we stayed away from the hills and we
were fine
and um
just flew all the way out there and i
got to tell you i kind of love flying
out there because there's nobody out
there
and uh and then also if you have an
engine failure
i jokingly said i said hey if i quit
where would you put it and he just
laughed because you put it anywhere
where like you know when you fly the la
basin it's like you know you're picking
a road or some [ __ ] field or some
[ __ ]
um usually a street like i always you
always think you can fit into the field
but yeah i i don't know how the [ __ ] you
do that
um
it always seems too small to me and
there's always trees around it and then
you'd have to come and steep it just
just looks like it would be bad so we
anyway we flew out there ended up flying
to this airport called victorville
or in victorville i should say and as we
came in
landed on the runway 1-7
and as we were coming in i just see all
of these jumbo jets
jumbo
jumbo jets just parked
i guess they were all timed out
and they're just sitting there
and i'm telling you man there must have
been 30 40 50 of those things
fedex planes qantas
and united
airplanes just sitting there
i actually took a video of it i might
post it on my instagram
um
it was pretty [ __ ] wild and i was
just thinking like what did they do with
those things
i kind of became uh
got like obsessed with that and a buddy
of mine just sent this a documentary
this guy made
of visiting those jumbo jet um
graveyards that i'm gonna watch tonight
let me see if i can get the name of it
for you now that i i might have piqued
your interest here
see what this [ __ ] thing is here
um
i'm singing chips
the [ __ ] is it
come on man oh there it is the perverts
guide to ideology abandoned planes in
mojave desert
oh so that's literally where i was at
i gotta watch this it's on youtube
check that out um if you get a chance
um so anyway i'd like to address some of
these these uh buffalo bills fans
you know
i got a couple kids so i haven't been
looking at the standings the level of
[ __ ] that you guys have been talking
and evidently you have the same record
as the patriots
i i don't understand this uh especially
with the track record of your franchise
i don't understand where this
confidences
is coming from
we've played each other twice
we won the first one you won the second
one
we're nine and six you're nine and six
or whatever the [ __ ] we are
like
i don't
i just don't understand
there's two games left
what if you lose the next two games
and we go one and one and we win the
next two games
then what happens
for the life of me i just don't unders i
don't understand the world of [ __ ]
talkers
you know
it's weird because they lose a lot but
they just maybe i don't know they just
keep their confidence up
yeah i don't understand and also like
the level of celebration over a [ __ ]
regular season win
it's like all right uh you know okay
all right
i guess um something happened i mean you
won a huge game and i loved the way you
guys came in and you [ __ ] took it to
us but like you know
i wouldn't break all the tables out
there just yet
[Music]
bill why you being a killjoy they
haven't had anything to [ __ ] cheer
about since [ __ ] jim kelly left all
right fair enough
fair enough i i just don't like you know
i'm [ __ ]
i guess i tease him a little bit
i don't i actually like the bills i'd
like the bills going back to oj
you know
back in the day
joe cribbs
joe ferguson
joe delamuler i was a fan
fred smirless
from massachusetts by the way i believe
at least they went to bc i was a fan
i don't know what happened
it just i don't know they real i don't
know maybe it's the weather
this [ __ ]
i don't know you know something every
every town has sports fans like that
maybe that's what it is anyways oh billy
[ __ ] woodshed though has been going
around this doing around town putting
together his new hour
putting it
together and i have a whole mismatch of
funny unconnected silly [ __ ] and um i
did two shows monday i did one last
night
and i'm gonna keep working it
out in phoenix and i think i'm gonna
have this hour together
sooner rather than later and um
[Music]
yeah and then i'll be ready for my tour
the brand new hour and then my i can put
out the [ __ ] red rock thing that is
the plan
that is
the plan man
so uh we shall see
we shall see what's happening um
been playing a little bit of drums
you know
got back into like listening to like
miles davis like he put out like
like four albums
in the 50s
it was like cooking with miles relaxing
with miles
chilling with miles
[ __ ] put your feet up with miles
and i was never able to get through the
records i could just never get through
them because i just you know
my [ __ ] hair metal background i
trying to listen to it and [ __ ]
and um
i went back and i was listening to him
today and i really liked that relaxing
with miles one
and um
i don't know i was just more into his
the [ __ ] he did in the 60s
you know that four and more album
in a silent way
uh i'll tell you know it's a [ __ ]
great album that got [ __ ] all over that
he has is that on the corner
[ __ ] crazy album and they got so [ __ ]
on i think he like
just i think it was the last album he
put out for a while till like
2-2 in the early 80s like a complete
album
then i was reading today he like retired
from music in like 1975.
i'm fascinated with retiring
i'm not gonna lie to you i just damn
like i want like after
this you can't you guys still have to do
[ __ ]
you have to do so you got to get a hobby
then you're doing that you have to do
something you just be bored out of your
[ __ ] mind but there is just something
if you just had enough money to keep the
lights on and get a sandwich every day
can you imagine how [ __ ] amazing that
would be because i always find this this
time of year is [ __ ] depressing where
it's just like
you get all this [ __ ] for christmas
there's all these empty boxes and you're
filling up your recycling bin you're
going out there you're trying to mash it
down and street sneak around to your
neighbors but theirs is filled up too
you're just like what the [ __ ] are we
doing near please don't leave on this
you're gonna have where you going
she just came walking in
huh
oh he's crying because he can hear me
oh [ __ ] all right my fault
my fault i'll go into the closet
oh you've been in the closet for years
huh
all right
do i have the ability to do anything
that isn't loud in life
do i have the ability to not disturb
people
oh [ __ ] this just took me back
this took me back to when i was young
i'm in the closet right now that the
[ __ ] lights are out i forgot to put
it on i had a teacher do that to me one
time
long [ __ ] time ago i had a teacher
[ __ ] stick me
i was being a wise ass
in class
and this guy he had some commitments
extracurricular commitments to oversee i
don't get anybody in trouble here
he had some extracurricular commitments
after school that took like an hour and
he wanted me to stay after school but he
couldn't let the other kids down
so he had a windowless room with the
closet door he [ __ ] locked me in
there
for like an hour and i was such a dumb
[ __ ]
i could have demanded an a in that class
if i knew how if i understood what
blackmail was
um there could have been a fire
but um
yeah
it was actually kind of funny
and i remember telling all my friends
the next day and they were all laughing
their ass off and then i was loving it
because i was getting laughs
and i didn't give a [ __ ]
you know but if i was like today's kids
i would have been in touch with my
feelings and would have been like i just
i thought you're there to help me grow
and blossom as a person and i would have
got all [ __ ] upset about it instead i
was you know
walled off with my emotions
you know i had never died in a fire at
that point in my life so i wasn't that
wasn't on the table for me even thinking
about that
so it was actually the whole thing was
kind of funny
ah [ __ ]
yeah i remember a long time ago
jesus almost 30 years ago whenever i
first started doing stand-up right
i ran into this
i ran into this guy i used to work with
and i was like hey man i started talking
he's looking at me like who the [ __ ] he
had no
[ __ ] idea i worked with this guy for
like two straight years and he had no
[ __ ] idea who i was
no [ __ ] idea who i was
and then i remember like 15 years later
i was finally selling tickets and
everything and he came out to my show
and he's like hey man
oh my god
oh i [ __ ] bursted out laughing i was
like what's up how you doing i just
[ __ ] laughed it [ __ ] is [ __ ]
hilarious
hilarious yeah so anyways
yeah that dude uh
yeah man there was all kinds of [ __ ]
like that when i was [ __ ]
coming up that just [ __ ] happened
that the teachers just could just you
know
they kept you in line back then
just thinking now if you did that if you
did that today that would be on nbc
nightly [ __ ] news it would be
considered that important
and no one would ever ask what did the
[ __ ] wise ass little [ __ ] do in class
you
know even if he was a little ginger like
me they still would give a [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] amazing
it's [ __ ] amazing how much people
care about other people nowadays
you know
while ignoring that we're all filling up
our recycling base bins now
you know this is the blue one this for
recycling it's all going in the ocean
when was the last time you bought
something out of something that was
recycled
i think i got one toy this year
one toy one relative got it actually was
a helicopter was cool it was made out of
old recycled uh
milk cartons
and i was like well that's [ __ ] cool
there's a there's a there's a ray of
light
which this podcast has not been jesus
christ i'm [ __ ] on bills fans
what else retirement suicide
i'm sorry let me let me [ __ ] bring it
around here
bring it around to a sunshiny place
um
i will tell you though the uh
writing a whole new hour stand up is one
of my favorite [ __ ] things in the
world to do just going up there and just
[ __ ] bombing
and just saying ridiculous some of the
[ __ ] i said i said the other night
i was sick of seeing regular women with
designer bags
it was like what
i don't even know why i said it and then
i just had to go with it like i believed
it like i actually cared
it was like the most fun three minutes
of that day other than playing with my
kids
which by the way has been a blast man we
uh
i got my daughter this electric car that
you can drive around the driveway it's a
little two-seater thing is [ __ ]
hilarious
so she's driving my son around he's all
excited there's little seat belts it's
got little lights on and stuff it is
[ __ ]
incredible i'm looking at that thing
like if they [ __ ] had one of those
things when i was a kid
it's incredible
um
but anyway you actually really learn how
to drive like she's learning that like
you know when you go to back up you got
to cut the wheel
you know i don't have the biggest
driveway so uh
at first i thought that that was gonna
be
like a bad thing because you couldn't
just cruise up and down the driveway i
got like a small driveway but now i'm
realizing it's actually kind of a good
thing because she's she's actually
learning how to drive but she loves it
and of course like this is the time of
year that it rains so she hasn't been
able to drive so
she's going dad can we
do you want to uh you want to go outside
and watch me drive my car i want to
drive my car
ah it's [ __ ] adorable
um
so anyway um
it's new year's coming up people what
are you doing what are your new year's
resolutions me i'm gonna finally lose
this last like eight pounds of the 20
that i that i put on
i gotta finally just knock it out
um
it's funny i gave away all my cigars to
the troops i hope they got
to you guys um
but then like
i've just been going out to cigar bars
and buying them but i'm just buying sort
of one and two at a time
but i think i'm still smoking as much as
i ever did the whole thing is just
stupid i just gotta like lay off it
but uh that's gonna happen after the new
year i'm gonna smoke way less cigars
however
however i am going to the rose bowl as
always
uh but this year we're not going to the
game
i think we finally realized after going
to ten straight rose bowls
that what we really enjoy is the
tailgate
and we're always bummed out when the the
game always comes to or we we get there
like seven in the morning
i pass out by 10 i wake up at noon and
then we have to [ __ ] that happens every
year
and uh i just don't pace myself i just
get so [ __ ] excited but the last
couple i've been sober so
um
yeah
i don't know what i've been doing oh
wait no
the last
two new years i've been sober but only
one of them i could go to the game
because a covid last year that's it all
right there we go so we're just going to
go there we're going to throw the ball
around maybe get a little generator
going
watch some of the ball games
hang out eat some food
just have a great time and while the
game's going we're going to [ __ ]
leave
like i did a few years ago because um
i remember doing that when my wife was
pregnant
with my daughter and she could have the
kid at any point
and she told me she goes all right now
don't go there and get all [ __ ] up at
the tailgate because god forbid i go
into labor then what i go okay honey and
i go there right and everybody's doing
shots and i say to myself right i'm just
gonna do one so i do one shot and
immediately i'm like frank the tank you
know
feels so good when it
when it touches your lips you know
so i proceed to get
mildly
[ __ ] up
and i keep checking in with her you know
i'll have like a shot in my hand i'm
going how you doing any anything going
on no all good i'm like all right and
then i would do like another shot it was
so stupid
so stupid and [ __ ] irresponsible
whatever
um
but uh that one ended up leaving the
game early
i remember it actually felt good
to just not sit in the traffic i wasn't
as [ __ ] up
and i think that that's i don't know it
started to click like maybe you should
go a little easier
and not go so [ __ ] hard um
so you know
i've been [ __ ] stone sober since i
tried mushrooms for one the one and only
time
back in february
and um
i don't know i think i'm going to just
keep doing this [ __ ] i think maybe every
once in a while
if the timing is right
if i have an extra day on the road or
something or maybe like one of those
therapy things i would do like a
mushroom thing again but other than that
i think i'm i'm like [ __ ] good
um
although you know when the toughest one
is the toughest one
is when um if i take like a vacation
with my wife
that's a hard one
you know
to not have a couple of drinks or
something like that i mean what the [ __ ]
but i know why i know why because then
it always ends up then it's just
something i have to [ __ ] quit again
which i don't want to [ __ ] deal with
not jesus christ all right
so this is me
in a dark closet flashing back
um
to a younger time in my life this is uh
been the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast we have
the uh the segment that everybody's been
loving with paul verzi the bet mgm
segment i'm gonna let you know uh
because we didn't do anything better
podcast this week
we did like a 40-minute thing talking
about the nfl
and honoring the great john madden if
you thought for some reason i forgot to
bring
literally um
just the absolute king
he just
on all levels absolutely
was the best
he he just looked like he looked like us
he looked like a football fan he played
football he loved football
you know
the way he didn't he never looked right
in a sport coat he just looked like he
should be standing around a hibachi
just talking about the game and
everything and um
i don't want to repeat anything that i
said on the podcast but we give him uh a
respectful send-off
um
i mean jesus that's just an absolute
giant
uh who's no longer with us and uh
if you are a football fan a fan of the
nfl you are a more knowledgeable fan
because of that great man um all right
that is it enjoy here's the bad mgm
segment what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast nfl
preview edition for week number set
we're going into week 17 we will go over
week 16 but first we gotta believe it 17
paul where does it go it's over it's
[ __ ] over um
got to thank our sponsor the best
sponsor in the game with betting the
most reliable betting's uh
betting app there is out there which is
bet mgm guys as you know the anything
better podcast has teamed up with bet
mgm at the beginning of the season we'll
be using all of their lines to make our
picks we'll have special offers for our
listeners each week if you haven't
signed up to bet mgm yet use a bonus
code bur
b-u-r-r and you'll get two hundred
dollars free after placing your first
ten dollar bet 100 smackaroos
for free 200 bones here's how it works
you download the bet mgm app to sign up
using bonus code bur that's b-u-r-r very
very easy you place your first 10 money
line bet on any nfl game that there is
you'll receive 200 in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome i'm going to
say that again regardless if you [ __ ]
the bed and you make a awful prediction
you're still fine all right that's
unheard of uh so it doesn't matter the
outcome just make sure you use bonus
code burp b-u-r-r when you sign up now
going into week 16 bill and i somehow
survived this coveted [ __ ] storm and we
ended up no harm no foul but
nobody gained any ground both going two
and two hey bill dude how wrong was i
about that charge again i was so pissed
i was like oh man why did i say i'm
taking the jets first
and the jets end up
before he's not covered they ended up
losing dude i i i swear to god i can't i
just can't 100 blame covert man i kind
of i've lost the angles paul and you
know what i'd let you hang around and i
got no one to blame it myself i am one
bad week away
from just you know fumbling the [ __ ]
extra point snap here well listen
i'm one week away from losing it and
you're one we good week away from a
title speaking of which
after
after the week okay after all of these
weeks
bill's record is 35 28 and one against
the spread my record is i'm sorry 35 28
1 minus 34 and 30. so bill is five and a
half games beating the book on four
games beating the book which means the
anything better podcast has made you
people money let's call a spade let's go
you're doing what we're telling you to
do and you put even money on everything
yeah with the juice they're probably
still getting you but you're telling me
that they're doing it better on the
network than that because somebody has
on a sport coat and they used to play
the game doesn't mean they know how to
gamble paul that's right speaking of
which we fi i found the perfect meme i
sent it to paul
that if you've never gambled before and
you want to know what it's like to have
money on a game
all right this video is the difference
between the first half
and the second half betting on the
football game here it is right here hey
you got to start from the beginning
you got to say i love i love the wave oh
my god i'm up 14-7 interception [ __ ]
i told you i told
sorry i was wrong
dude that was you in october right here
when you get ready to start
high-stepping and then i came back and
then in december i thought i had you i'm
like mercy's going down again i went for
dude he's lucky he didn't go under that
[ __ ] thing and get killed oh my god
that's brutal
i mean i don't even know can you imagine
i want to see the rest of the video i
just want to figure out who was the
person that got in and stopped that
thing
watch his hat watch his hat in his head
that's the difference between dating a
woman and marrying her dude she loves me
she's always like
she would never [ __ ] me over once i
swear she's easy going you know
ah
all right man we're going into week 17
bill we are starting the fourth quarter
of the nfl season
and uh it's pretty nuts um it's an odd
week which means i get the first pick
and i had literally two minutes to look
at these and boy these are good good
these two these are tough dude because
some teams need it other teams you don't
know if they're going for a draft but
paul have you ever watched a season of
football
where there's been more teams
this flip-flopping where they just look
like they're on a run
yeah i mean is the season so long now
it's becoming like basketball where a
team's up 12
and then the other team goes on a 15-2
run
it's unreal the buffalo bills
yeah look like world beaters look like
they were [ __ ] in the bed
and now they're kind of back well i just
got to tell you something all those bill
fans i don't know what they're so
[ __ ] excited about they're just tied
with us
we both went one and one so what is the
big thing there's two games left and god
knows that there's two games left and
you can shut the bed i mean that's
pretty much uh that's that's their motto
out there so
they're celebrating a little too early
having said that i do i do like the
bills well
yeah and then you could also look at
what the chiefs are doing because the
chiefs seem like they're back but i
still don't like them against a good
defense in the playoffs
um
there's so many teams like that all
right get what do you got paul who are
you coming out with
uh
you know i i dude i gotta be honest with
you i feel like i'm flipping a coin with
some of these games some of these lines
are high
i think
they're ridiculously high
yeah dude 12 and a half 14 and a half
seven and a half
they look like college spreads in
september
uh the bill's 14 and a half just scares
the [ __ ] out of me
um yeah and who the [ __ ] is atlanta
one week they're beating tom brady
buccaneers and next week they're [ __ ]
getting smoked by i don't like carolina
or something
[ __ ] saints are the same way too
dude the dolphins titans game is the
hardest game for me to pick i just
honestly don't know
all right dude
here it goes my first pick
um going into this week
i gotta see if they're for real
i'm gonna take
i'm gonna take the tennessee titans over
to miami dolphins even though miami's
won like eight in a row
i gotta see it it's like it's like when
somebody sit is is bluffing with the
poker hand and they're throwing the
chips in i gotta see it so i gotta see
if the titans could do it so i'm taking
tennessee at home
to to stifle the hottest team in
football could be the dumbest pick of
the year
i don't know i'm just i'm going with the
titans at home i don't know i mean
they've won eight in a row
they are the dolphins and i think mike
grebel is a great coach is that in in
miami
no
hey you know
you never know all right i'm uh i'm
buying in on two things
i'm finding that the cowboys are legit
and i'm buying in that arizona is
finished
i've been on arizona the whole [ __ ]
year and they've been great and then
lately i don't know what's going on they
got injuries they got covered they got
sunstroke i don't know what their deal
is
the phoenix coyotes are thinking they're
moving there's a whole bunch of turmoil
going and i'm gonna be there on thursday
so i think that all goes in it's only
five and a half i'm buying it
i'm taking the cowboys
in five and a half
oh bill you thought about that one and
you're going to be there i like it i
like the pic
um
i'm not going to be at the game i'm just
i'm going in uh by the time this thing
airs i was there thursday i had two
shows
i hope you made it
i'm gonna take
after a after an embarrassment against
the houston texans
after the chargers threw justin herbert
through a couple of pics i believe there
was a fumble in there
the hapless texans beat up on the
chargers and now the chargers back back
the jaguars did
huh didn't the jaguars beat up
no texas it was the texans beat the [ __ ]
out of them like 40 something to 20
something
now the chargers come home minus six and
a half i think they'll beat the broncos
um by a touchdown teddy bridgewater is
out and um the chargers need to bounce
back so i'll take the chargers to win by
a touchdown against the broncos oh i
might blow this whole thing this week
bill
no i don't know i i can't find my picks
here like i don't know
oh boy
just christ
is because uh
i [ __ ] um
my internet's all [ __ ] up uh who else
did i have
oh i know i'm taking uh
i'm taking the colts
that running game and carson wentz
scores points i wanted that one
hey paul last week i wanted the charges
i think two weeks before i wanted
another game that you picked
and uh we're picking eight games it's
gonna happen we're picking eight games
of [ __ ] week here so
paul versi uncharacteristically
unsure of himself this could be the week
you go 4-0
this could be the week i go home four
just [ __ ] end it um i'm going with
joe burrow
and the cincinnati bengals plus five and
a half against the chiefs at home
they're flying high the kid just threw
500 and something yards
i think the bengals need to really make
a statement if they're for real this
year and this is the game to do it i
think even if the uh if cincinnati loses
i think they lose by less than five and
a half i'm taking cincy at home
joe burrows gonna be smoking a cigar
after that game just like he did when
lsu won the championship against clemson
i was at that game right before the
covet came oh i ain't nothing i am
scared
oh i'm scared
all right i'm going with the team that
for some reason nobody believes in but i
believe in them i'm going with the
seattle seahawks
playing the [ __ ] lions
wow at home
i like that game
a game that doesn't matter he's going
with i was thinking of one of those
games i mean it doesn't it doesn't
matter pete carroll is gonna have to
sell his home with the grotto up there
in seattle if they don't get a victory
all right i'm looking for pete carroll
to be going whoa
like ric flair like he does all the time
after they score a touchdown russell
wilson i still believe
okay if if russell wilson played in new
york city paul
come on he's out there in seattle just
crushing it and his his expression drop
it down the bucket now everybody say
dropped it down the bucket that's
russell will he should have trademarked
that
he's the guy who does it
um
dude russ i mean pete carroll's going to
have the fbi show up to his house for
tax evasion he's gonna run out the back
door
you can't get him
he's like a great comic book villain
there's always room for a sequel
he's the doc ock of the nf of a football
coaching
all right i'm gonna take my new york
football jet i'm kidding um dude he
tried to teach he literally you know the
end of fargo
when william h macy tries to go out the
window he did that at usc and got out
yeah
what was the movie with uh what was the
movie with the the dude tim robbins
what was this shawshank redemption yeah
carol climbed through
six miles of [ __ ] on his hands and knees
to get to seattle dude
i think everything he did there they
took away they did everything but tear
up the field
take the band uniforms
uh heisman trophies championships
that was job it was something paul he
didn't do what the warden did the warden
just offed himself when he saw the cops
coming
um
he was thinking of doing something
stupid and taking a few with them he's
just like ah what's it gonna matter
is taste some hill playing cause if
taysom hill is playing the saints are
gonna beat the panthers at home
i'm gonna i'm gonna pet you right now
paul there's not another person in this
in this country named taysom
it's gotta be it's gotta be some
southern [ __ ] and i'm not talking about
somebody named after him
that's a very hard thing to do to come
up with a name
that nobody
came up with and it's not like an
[ __ ] name because that's a cool name
like you know like these hollywood
celebrities they name their kid like
butter
apple
as of now he's not as of now he's not
playing
you know what game is you know what game
is interesting i you should have said
intriguing paul you're touching your
chin
your game is intriguing
[Music]
i'm gonna take the pittsburgh steelers i
know it's stupid but i'm gonna take the
pittsburgh steelers after being so
embarrassed at home
i mean
in december paul
there's nothing to be embarrassed about
i love that he lost last week and got
embarrassed do you think ben's gonna sit
there and
big ben is the john wayne the modern-day
john wayne
she's shaking stuff off people bounce
off them
they're getting three points at home
they got embarrassed on national
television bad against the chiefs i'm
gonna take big ben which could be his
second to last game ever his last is it
his last game home it might be his last
game home dude that guy is a throwback
that guy is a 1970 i'll tell you he's a
1970s football
player and that and domica sue should
have been playing in the 1960s with with
sam huff and dick butkus
stepping on guys and you could do all of
that if you watch those old nfl films
that just guys playing in the wrong era
i love both of them i just think that
the coach and him have too much pride to
go out like the way they did last week
and then come home and do it do it again
so i'm gonna take them getting three at
home i gotta tell you out of all the
weeks we've been doing this
this is the one it might be because it's
coming down to the end this is the one
that scares me this is the one that
scares me but we'll see i've already
given into the fact that this ain't my
year
so i'm just shooting from the hip here
and that's why i think for the first
time this season i'm going to go with
the monsters of the midway
against your new york football giants
i have out of respect i waited to the
end
to see if you wanted that game
no you didn't take it i know you can't
bet against your own team so
uh paul versus still as he's competitive
as he is
the man has a good heart
he cannot benefit
i mean last week i wanted to take the
bills i just had a feeling about that
game
um we both laid off that yeah i just i
was like you know i gotta i gotta now
also i gotta tell you
as much as i hate that we lost i loved
how the bills came out in that first
drive
they just rammed it right down our
throat and then and they they were like
they came to [ __ ] play and they
needed that was one of the biggest games
the bills have had
since probably the jim kelly era
oh they went in and they they took the
game but i was also happy that we came
back
but uh i i you got to respect how the
bills came in and play well speaking of
respect and i'm glad i thought of this
we have no choice on this show but to
pay tribute to the unbelievable life of
john madden john madden's voice was
literally
like
you know the way they say nobody's
bigger than the game he is the one guy
like somebody said on twitter john
madden is football
and dude you know what he said i saw
something today the game you guys beat
us i don't know if you saw this on
twitter the game you guys beat us in
week 16 to go 16-0 when coughlin decided
to not lay down and really play you guys
and you guys i was at that game i told
you about that game where moss was that
he broke the record tomorrow so you guys
won 38.35
we made one mistake you guys made none
it was it was nuts
madden called coughlin and they played
the voicemail today
and he goes
he goes i don't mean to get emotional he
goes but the fact that you didn't lay
down
and like you because because the giants
had made the playoffs and there was a
question if the giants were going to
arrest starters going into tampa bay and
coughlin goes let's try to stop this
streak and madden had called him and
said you just it was like good for
football you did good for football and
then he goes and i remember seeing the
cults the colts wrestling players and
they took their foot off the gas and it
just you got to just keep going you got
to keep going
um i actually went to two super bowls
that john madden and pat summerall the
greatest announcing team oh yes i ever
heard they called both games i went when
we lost to the packers and brett favre
and um when we won against the rams in
and um
i got like
i remember you know going back because i
went to the game and i would tape it and
watch it afterwards i remember going
back and watching the loss
and just thinking is john madden ever
going to be able to say that you know
the patriots won one and and when i was
at that game
and the patriots kicked it and wanted
the the the thing that was on i was so
freaked out about this is back in the
days of vcrs did my vcr tape
because i want to hear what he's saying
about my finally john madden with all of
his knowledge is going to say something
great about
you know our team but that guy just like
dude the guy won a hundred games
seven division titles in in a super bowl
in seven years with the raiders he put
him on the map he's the re the whole
commitment to excellence he's right
there with al davis
i mean
the guy what he did for offensive
lineman
he got me to start watching offensive
linemen and realize how cool that was
and just not think that just you know
really cool people were the ones with
the ball with the guys stopping the
person with the ball
um
him diagramming the plays
it was like
i i just
and he just he loved like being a raider
he loved people that had you know crazy
personalities
and um
i don't know i saw something this
morning
you know i was at the gym and i s the
sound was down i saw it was john madden
ken stabler and then there was another
john madden and jack tatum and i was
just man all of those guys are gone now
i just cannot believe how much time has
gone by and how crazy is it that they
they finally did this epic documentary
on him
it was perfect
it was perfect and they just summed him
up he got to say what he said he got to
thank everybody he got to realize what
he meant to everybody and then he just
dies in natural causes basically in his
sleep no long-term illness or anything a
big guy like that
living to 85 eating whatever the hell he
wanted to eat i mean that guy lived one
of the charmed lives lives i've i've
ever seen his kids love him
you know uh got into the hall of fame
and he did al davis was still alive
um
though the turkey legs the all madden
team you ever see you see that in the
documentary they were sitting out there
guys would get it more upset
you know that they did make them the all
madden team because he was saying you
know being on the allman team meant you
were a man
he played the game the way he was
supposed to play it it wasn't just stats
or whatever
yeah um
yeah it's um
i don't know it sucks but
uh
i don't know i'm kind of
he deserved to go out the way he went
out with an epic documentary
and and no illness
and just going peacefully like that it's
amazing that he yeah i agree but it's
amazing that they just did that
documentary and you see him sitting on
the couch watching it and smiling and
then he just kind of just
was like just goes off and in his sleep
it's like a beautiful life it's this
amazing thing and
the end of joe pesci's acting career in
the irishman he literally waves goodbye
it's amazing yeah in real time i was
like that is the perfect ending to an
acting career i've ever seen
john madden
one-upped him with the perfect ending to
her life here's another thing too i love
about that guy
is he could take a compliment
he wasn't all fidgeting when people were
saying great stuff about him
he just had a big smile on his yourself
just seemed like the warmest guy
hey you know what
you know joe bartnick met him one time
i'm gonna tell the bartnik story oh wow
uh he was going into radio or somewhere
near a stadium and john mann came out so
he was walking out they like oh my god
john man jump in he was kind of like
yeah hey hey like who are these lunatics
and bartnik goes hey
he goes today is the greatest day of
your life
but only if you win
he he said his super bowl speech and the
guy just stopped and he was like oh hey
fellas and then he just
sat and actually talked to him but
bartnik got to t you know you got it
yeah it's just like all right i know i'm
famous i do the light beer for miller
and stuff and bartnik got him
with quote in a deep cut
yeah a side b
i i had the um i want to say something
about john madden after but you got to
hit something that's different when you
see a guy like that and i did the same
thing with mariano rivera he was outside
yankee stadium he was on a suit they
were getting on a bus to go to one of
the pitcher's birthday parties
everyone's young moe
is doing the whole typical really nice
waving but really not looking at anybody
and he's doing everything he's just
looking all you know he was really thin
actually for for what he did and how
hard he threw and i just everyone's
yelling stuff and i just go
greatest ever dude and he just stopped
and he just looked and he just gave this
thing and it was like that was
and
when you do that to them like when you
hit the cord that they want to be hit
but the thing about madden was
you said you wanted to hear him say
something about the patriots or what
they what what it was finally going to
say when your team won
he never was biased against a team he
was opposite of tim mccarver tim
mccarver hated the yankees he had the
[ __ ] redstock every team that caught
him he had this thing when he called the
games and you could feel it madden was
always like complimentary he was always
like this guy is great when he puts his
head down he's great this coach is great
this organization deserves that that's
my kind of player positivity
hanging out he's bloody
big guy boom and he would go boom he's a
big guy boom and he always he goes it's
not a it's not a hit or it's not a crash
he goes it's boom but anyway man um and
the video games growing up i'm growing
up that's the one game still to this day
i'll go to a friend's house but hey man
you want to go go madden and um just the
guy was football so yes and the truth
you know what's crazy he's the guy that
i got that kick the field goal you take
the points and it's like i'm listening
to a hall of fame coach and blah blah
but
in 2001 when i went back and i listened
to that playback when the patriots
didn't lay down and just play for the uh
the overtime
he said on the mic he goes i don't agree
with this and then he watched
basically the beginning of the brady
legend and he then he said a couple
plays later he said what either said
what the patriots or what brady is doing
right now is giving me the chills
and then adam vinatieri if is there a
field goal did john stennerud make it in
if there's not a field goal kicker in
the hall of fame
adam benatari not only should be in the
hall of fame should be a first ballot
hall of famer wait what did madden not
agree with what did he say i don't agree
with he thought that we should have just
taken a knee and gone and played in
overtime
because he thought they're gonna be
slinging the ball you're risking a
turnover and you know it was a real
like madden was just after that three
yards in a clouded dust era
of football before united and the colts
opened it up
um
you know uh uh paul brown and autogram
with uh
uh lou the toe groza were all like they
were throwing the ball
but they also they blew the toe bros the
offensive lineman kicked it straight on
i remember that
yeah he was the one you know when they
were trying to figure out why paul brown
was so successful
like they didn't take the kicking game
seriously and he did and you get three
here you get three there you get three
there next you know he got an extra nine
points and you lose by two or whatever
um
that's all
anymore bill cause you're getting me all
excited now because i've been texting
everybody does a field goal exist
because uh what's it called the one team
went forward in the red zone on fourth
down five times and [ __ ] lost the
game nobody takes points from the
20-yard line when they're [ __ ] right
there and it's just it's crazy i feel
like
it's crazy
i feel like the fans enjoy watching you
go for it on fourth down
and not making it more than they enjoy a
field goal so you'd almost don't get
called out on it but i'll tell you like
you know last week the bills went right
down it was fourth and two
fourth and goal right two yards away
from the goal line
and they went for it and i was like this
is the dumbest [ __ ] call just get the
points but then they made it and it's
like so they compil they combine coming
out ramming it down our throats fourth
and two we believe in ourselves
and they scored the touchdown and then
the very next drive we were like fourth
fourth and whatever a couple of yards on
our own 50 down seven or nothing after a
very impressive drive we went for it ran
a sweep and we got it so
i mean i don't know what the numbers are
on it but i will say
the thing about it is
is
i guess if you go for it and you make
it in a game like the patriots versus
the bills
after they
they did it it really made sense
because i was it was like
it was already deflating like [ __ ] man
these guys really came to play and you
could just see us on our heels like whoa
whoa
we came to play but you guys are really
playing and the fact that they didn't go
down and just do a little kick for uh
and we're down three nothing it's sort
of like a little bit of a victory after
the way they came out the fact that they
went down and scored the touchdown
i i i have to you know i i agree with it
in that
i mean i don't it's weird to say i agree
with it after i saw that it worked
but like
i'm still not sold on
if you didn't get it the momentum switch
of that
um
i didn't go and set it down your throat
and then we stopped you on the goal line
and now we have the momentum i don't
know it's it's a big risk one one thing
about oh good sorry
being turned down by joe montana ea
sports approached john madden in 1982
with the idea of creating a video game
skeptical at first madden eventually
agreed as he saw it as a way to educate
fans on the game of football the only
problem madden was a perfectionist ea
sports spent years working on a
prototype only to have john madden shut
it down immediately upset that it was 7
verse 7 football and didn't integrate
any of the nfl playbook
madden made them start over seven years
and many uh revisions later uh john
madden football was released in 1988.
that's awesome
that's [ __ ] awesome dude that's right
when they asked bill walsh to write a
book
he wrote this book and he just wrote it
about football
and like breaking down like the cover
two and all the west coast offense and
all that and the publisher was just like
dude we can't publish this he goes well
that's the kind of book i'm writing
and
it didn't sell well but it is considered
like a bible
amongst football coaches because they
all go out and buy it here's something
else about john manning
the only other guy i saw do this where
after they retired
long after they retired his name still
meant something it was still madden
football madden football man for jordan
they still put out jordans there's a new
jordans every year the guy's been
retired for 20 years there's only two
guys yeah that were ever big enough that
they ever did that for so um that's a
great point yeah yeah i i just i don't
know man like
that's what i mean bigger than the game
it's like it's like it's john madden
dude
it's yeah it's it's great man and
everybody and and on top of it all his
voice
his voice was so
unique and so like you could be like
they said uh uh kevin harlan said the
guy who was actually called more super
bowl games than anybody like kevin
harlan right between the eyes he said he
goes when when uh somebody or somebody
said when john madden's voice was on
like on a tv and you heard it you had to
just like when you heard john max
you just had to watch
you know you knew it was an important
game because him and pat did the most
important game every single week
um there's another thing too was he just
looked like a regular guy too he looked
like the big guy at the tailgate i
remember me my older brother used to
laugh
when he first got in the booth
was my brother used to laugh because uh
or he's on like almost on the panel on
on on tv before the game he would have a
sport coat on with short sleeves
underneath it so like you know his
wrists would be showing which was a big
no-no in haberdashery back then and he
just didn't give a [ __ ] because he
wasn't a suit
and uh he just you know
i just love the way he looked in a suit
too he looked like
he did never wore a suit except it like
christmas or thanksgiving or a funeral
he just had that
every every man thing about him man it's
um i gotta be honest with you i don't
think uh
you know i don't think his shoes have
been filled yet
someone has yet to step in
um
they're gonna have to be totally
like unique because there's been some
great guys like tony romo might be my
favorite is like tony romo i think is
the best football educator
since john madden came in the league
where like
um
the stuff he says before the play and
it's and it ends up being it's like
it's it's like the guy's like eight
seconds in the future
um troy aikman i love
joe buck troy eichman i love those guys
uh um
tony romo
obviously al michaels and colin they've
been around forever they're my favorite
they're my favorites i think they're the
they're my favorites because they're
just so like chris comsworth just sits
there and he's so as a matter of fact
and great and he's never shits on
anybody like the thing we were saying
with madden al michael's voice i gotta
be honest al michael's voice for me is
really really close to you know like you
know he's the guy you know do you
believe in miracles but then all of
those big games he's done too so
i get a good al michaels makes me feel
good hearing them i just feel you
imagine like if you know when they have
those verses the rappers have verses
if you were like an announcer
you got to throw bob costas in there too
that guy goes back to the end the aba
dunking contest yes
all right
if al michaels and bob costas had a
versus
because they're they're both
broadcasters right
well they weren't former athletes
whether they're broadcasters i mean you
were talking about
you're basically talking the history of
american sports
for the last 40 plus years
yeah i mean al michaels if he did the
1980 olympics i mean how big was that
guy to get called on to do the olympics
yeah it's like stepping in for john
mckay at that point
and bob costas goes back to the aba
which was the early 70s
so i mean you're talking about when he
was calling those game will chamberlain
was still playing in the nba i mean it's
just unbelievable nobody wanted that
game that al michaels called the dude
the miracles game that nobody wanted
that game that was like bottom of the
totem pole young guy yeah you get it
because they just thought it wasn't
going to be an interesting game because
i thought they were going to [ __ ]
russians were going to roll over them
and also hockey nobody liked hockey
in this freaking country didn't like it
enough but uh
what was i going to say al michaels is a
huge hockey fan
that's awesome
huge huge hockey fan yeah how would
broadca how would broadcasters battle
one guy's in a booth
guy finishing no he's at the 10. he's at
the father
oh he's going deep no you got to go dude
this is a great thing to do the greatest
calls
yeah of all time i mean like uh
i'm trying to think of some of the
classic do you believe in miracles yes
that's that's a top five
uh that might be a top three
top three i'm trying to think of the i'm
going [ __ ] blank now oh oh
down goes frasier down goes frasier is
frasier down goes fraser bird steals the
ball the ball or
an apple check steals it
those are the two big celtics ones what
was the baseball one shot round the
cardinals one when ozzie
smith go crazy folks go crazy the doug
flutie call oh i got one i got one he
did it he did it flutie did it that's it
oh and phelan got it and then the other
guy
how about this one how about this one
touch them all joe you'll never hit a
bigger home run in your life that's when
he went off great one that's a good one
that is a great one um as much as i hate
to say joe buck saying the curse is over
was pretty big
that was a pretty big one from the scene
that's a big one
come on dude joe buck's voice in in
october that is baseball that's good
that is baseball um
oh man this is really i know there's a
bunch of huge ones that i quote all the
time
um i can do the johnny most one
which one the one where bird sells the
ball well burnt steals the ball i think
it was uh
and owen burns steals it over to dj he
lays it up and in yeah oh my god this
place is going crazy
[Laughter]
i got a list pulled up here number one
do you believe in miracles uh number two
it's got uh the giants win the pennant
1951 by russ hodges oh that's a good one
down goes fraser frazier howard cassell
that's a great one i don't believe what
i just saw in 1988 joe buck
oh yeah i don't believe
what i just saw yeah oh that's another
great one gets through buckner 1986
vince scully
oh there's a little bounding ball of the
buckner behind the bag
it gets through bookner and then mets
win it yeah avalchek steals the ball
johnny most the band is on the field
1982 john joe start that's a great one
and the band is on the field yeah 2005
vern lindquist lundqvist uh
in your life have you ever seen that one
um
wait a minute 2005 which one was that
oh that was that was your game paul usc
it was at
all no wait is that that game i'm
guessing
vernon always did college
uh jack nick oh jack nicklaus 86 masters
i don't know um i don't know it's it's
blacked out here this websites thanks um
that's gotta be that's gotta be vince
young against usc right that was
pete carroll sanchez uh uh reggie bush
that was unreal dude that was
that's when pete carroll was in like the
montage
part of scarface when he was at usc
going to the bank with the money getting
counted and all of that stuff
looking at the tiger with his [ __ ]
wedding party bulletproof porsche he's
walking around with michelle pfeiffer
i'm sorry not sanchez it was matt liner
it was matt liner yeah
yeah yeah reggie bush
marv albert 1991 a spectacular move by
michael jordan
uh 1994. oh that was the uh when the the
switch of the hands one lay up against
the cavs maybe yeah there's a rangers 19
1994 howie rose
i think he switched hands against the
lakers
oh was it okay he switched he switched
hands against the lakers but uh
yeah that
you know what dude this there's not a
lot of them no
hey andrew you got to reach out to these
guys i want to do we got to do a versus
if we could get al michaels and bob
costas to go on and just talk about
oh my god just have a list of all the
greatest games and like how many of them
they were at
there's dude that would be nuts for them
to be like who did you i said they they
asked kevin harlan who was the most
impressive he ever saw and he said
watching jordan he said it was like the
guy wasn't on his feet it was like when
you watched him without the ball it was
like he was floating he goes you were
watching something different you imagine
asking costas or al michaels that do
with everything that they saw oh my god
dude
yeah i don't really know where they
could categorize it i was saying the
other day
the most electrifying because i saw
jordan when he had hair but it was a
scrimmage game
at the dean dome to get people excited
this is back in like 87 88 to get them
excited that nba basketball was coming
to charlotte with the the hornets
who later became the bobcats
later became the pelicans
um
so i saw him play and but he only played
like a half you know it was like a
scrimmage it wasn't a big deal it's the
most exciting person i ever saw play
live
as far as just electrifying in the crowd
on the edge of their seats was michael
vick in the georgia dome
pre-all that dog [ __ ] i mean he was
doing that dog [ __ ] but nobody knew at
that point
um dude every [ __ ] time he rolled out
of the pocket the whole place stood up i
don't care if he was on his own two-yard
line
and it was in a dome
my ears were ringing when i came out of
there it was he was he was [ __ ]
insane
insane it was literally like he was like
three steps faster than anybody else out
there um
i've been to a zillion games and i still
remember him running down zigzagging
across the field and then running down
the sidelines toward me i had like seats
on like the 20 or the 30 like mezzanine
or upper deck level
and just seeing him coming down
like dude i felt like i did leg day the
next day when after going
getting up and sitting down so many
times he was a blur man he was a [ __ ]
blur when he ran with the ball
yeah he was reckless though he was
reckless that's that's the one thing but
then he's the only guy to get two
200 he's the only guy to get two 100
million dollar contracts
he got a 100 million dollar contract
pre-dogs and then after he got out he
got a second chance and i believe the
eagles or somebody gave him another he
came back from that and was the eagles
it was eagles that's philadelphia
compared to what their fans are doing
drowning dogs that's like a misdemeanor
hey mike welcome home
what the [ __ ] else who else oh bo
jackson bo jackson was the most i didn't
get to see him live but mo bo jackson
uh pre-obviously pre the hip injury was
the most explosive thing i've ever seen
when that guy that guy was kevin walker
not that's a big trivia i think that's
the guy's name he's the guy who attacked
oh okay
bro hey what um
what uh so who's the best guy you ever
saw live
the best guy i ever saw live uh you know
i i saw
any sport i would say brady
and i saw 2007 brady
i saw i told you this and and for
anybody listening i don't know if i said
so i've never seen i forgot who i told
i've never seen in my lifetime
i was at that game where you guys went
16-0 38-35 you guys
the place stood up for the place stood
up
i want a meme of you the amount of times
you've said you this is the second time
on this podcast you said you had that
game yeah yeah
so
that that game and the usc texans
are your two go-to's
when you're an old man and kids say they
know about sports you're going to say
let me let me tell you say let me tell
you something 100 but
giant stadiums stood up
all but three plays i remember everybody
three plays people said that everybody
stood up but i'll never forget brady
walking to the line of scrimmage
with moss and all that 70 000 people
standing up screaming yelling and he
looked they looked like they were in a
[ __ ] at their practice facility
that's how calm i've never seen anything
like it he walked up people yelling i
was just like oh dude this was a they
were a machine dude and it was when he
broke the record for most touchdown
passes
i would think that a guy that won that
many super bowls i would say that that's
the greatest as far as i mean i saw him
on i saw mourinho i saw mourinho play um
yeah i saw mourinho i saw him a couple
of times coming into foxborough stadium
kicking her ass i got one for then we
got to wrap this up here uh because this
is we're literally doing a podcast here
yeah we got to do the monday night
special too so we gotta run all right no
the uh
the i'd say one of the best performances
i saw at a game that i wasn't at
was lawrence taylor they showed the game
um
during the madden documentary
where
madden was saying i never
thought one defensive player could take
over a game and win it and lawrence
taylor did and i remember uh
i remember that interception
and i remember when he caught it
that he was gonna go all the way and i
was so into football cards i remember
thinking like
i got excited
that i was gonna look on the back and
see you know interceptions and then see
one for a touchdown and then i saw it
dude i was in the football like that
that it was going to say all pro
underneath his name
and it was right that was sort of like i
think that game might have been the one
that um
put him on the map nationally
that everybody was like dude have you
seen that guy lawrence taylor oh my god
this guy that's where he reached right
he reached and got it and then ran yeah
i remember yep
i remember
um
man talking about this is awesome dude
we just did like uh but yeah we got to
get to this uh all right let's get to
the let's get to the pick here we gotta
get to the monday night uh special the
monday night special
win some money for you so here's the
deal because of the covet protocols and
all this stuff and people you know doing
whatever they're doing and getting
kicked out they told us to stick to the
money line the over under and then for
some reason we can still pick somebody
to score a touchdown so who's playing
cleveland browns it's the steelers and
and browns um
i took the steelers getting three at
home after that embarrassment so if you
want to take
you want to take the steelers with the
money line yeah i want to take this
deals with the money line
and uh what's the over under
uh
three
oh over under sorry 41.
41. i always break down dan katz's
[ __ ] rules that life is too short to
bet the under but i just like the under
in this i think that uh
i don't know i just i just like the
under i just think i just when i think
cleveland and pittsburgh i just don't
think a lot of points and i also think
defense
it's just the personality of both of
those franchises and uh
yeah it might be a tighter yeah more
more tight defense division division
rival tight defense all right so we'll
take the pittsburgh steelers with the
money line we'll take under 41 and
what's the third one
big ben's gotta throw one you know
dude they both are gunslingers man
i mean what's his face how many did uh
uh baker mayfield throw last week which
makes me think maybe they're not gonna
do it this week well he threw three
picks last week
one of them was [ __ ] one was it was
either a tip i forget
you know this is another thing too i
don't think quarterbacks throwing a hail
mary at the end of the game
at the end of a half i know should be
counted as a [ __ ] interception i
agree with that
yeah they're putting up a 50-50 ball at
the end of a half because there's two
seconds left it should there should be
some sort of category for that
yeah
um what what whatever you want we could
go we could roll with whatever you want
for the third one
i like both of our first ones i guess i
mean all right i would say what's his
face is going to score that that running
back for um
for the browns what the [ __ ] his name
nick
yeah
make sure there's no covet with nick
chubb
why did i think his last name was mack
uh
dude do yourself a favor you got me
thinking about that man i said bill who
was your buddy who worked as an agent
but then after he was an agent he ended
up helping with like finance like
players like with their financial stuff
do you remember that guy
yeah
but i got an old man brain right now dad
he i said to him one time he was
backstage at a show and i go dude what's
the greatest performance you ever seen
in sports history and he just goes he
goes dude vince young rose bowl and i i
think i hugged them i go yeah right
yeah i said i was like i never say
anything i never said they like it i
never said
job's playing um
what is it he's playing
all right so nick chubb russian
touchdown the the uh pittsburgh steelers
at the money line and under 41 for your
monday night special i like that man
that sounds like a winner to me
uh yeah i mean i just hope felicia
steelers
can pull it off
although none of that makes sense
i bet we bet the under and then i bet
that somebody on the other team is going
to score a touchdown
against the team that i've kicked
that's how you win money people
it doesn't make sense
let the monday nights pass you
win some money for you
all right
that's all right everybody new year
thank you to everybody that learning the
podcast and uh listening and all that
stuff we've been having a great time
and enjoying me and mercy going right
down to the wire a classic pitcher's
duel here paul
you know
if there's one thing that we can take is
whoever loses
which i'm really scared to lose him but
whoever loses as long as if we both beat
the book after 18 weeks that's something
so that's something it is why are you
scared i've never
i you've never beat me so i'm the one
who has something to lose here
yeah that's what i'm saying and like you
just be slinging it paul
no we haven't done this in what 10 years
and and you beat me 10 years ago i want
it i want it bill i want it i want the
jimmy the greek trophy we got to do
after this year we got to do it we got
to get a trophy
um andrew do you want me to read the
offering oh i won two back in the day in
the in the baa if i was the lakers i
would count those as [ __ ] titles um
all right guys well that's the thing uh
that's the episode that's the preview
please please use the bet mgm app it is
the best it's the most reliable most
reliable lines uh if you haven't signed
up just go to the app uh
mgm use bonus code burr bur r couldn't
be more easy two hundred dollars free
after placing a ten dollar bet okay so
you download the app you use burr as the
code you place a 10 money line bet any
nfl game you'll receive 200 in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you use bonus code bur when you sign up
and atlanta georgia i'm coming to the
punch line january 7th through the 9th
get your tickets we're going to sell
that place out and for all other tickets
go to paulversie.com
all right that's it everybody happy new
year we will see you in 2022.
visit betm.com for terms and conditions
years of age or older to wager arizona
colorado d.c iowa indianapolis louisiana
michigan missouri new jersey nevada
pennsylvania tennessee virginia west
virginia wyoming washington only all
promotions are subject to
qualification and eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawable free bets or site
credit free bets expire in seven days
from issuance excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call one
eight hundred next step in arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado d.c louisiana
nevada wyoming virginia 1-800-270-7117
for confidential help in michigan 1-800
gambler in indianapolis new jersey
pennsylvania and west virginia or 1-800
bets off in iowa call or text the
tennessee red line 800-889
tennessee or call 1-888-777-9696
in missouri or 1-800-547-6133
for washington that's 1-800-547-6133
sports betting is void in georgia hawaii
ohio and utah and other states
were prohibited promotional offers not
available in nevada
all right did i tell you or did i tell
you i told you we'd send them off right
um so that is it um
enjoy the music picked out by the
wonderful always wonderful andrew
themless and then we have a bonus half
hour of the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
happy new year to everybody thank you to
everybody that came out to my shows this
year
um so i can continue to not have a real
job
and uh
yeah that's it thank you guys so much
all right
go [ __ ] yourselves and have a great
weekend you [ __ ]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
um december 30th 2013.
oh my god it's the last monday of 2013
you guys
what are we gonna do with it
um
i'm actually still enjoying the holidays
i don't know about you guys usually by
at this point i'm so [ __ ] sick
of everything
and i do mean everything then i'm kind
of like almost excited to go back to
work but this year has been a great
thing other than seeing that [ __ ]
have yourself a merry little christmas
commercial like 58 [ __ ] times
every goddamn hockey game
you know or that one with the douche
who who
he's got a family right it's already
he's hateable
you know oh is that your little [ __ ]
fake television family
you know that didn't notice the film
crew watching you guys having a
christmas and he makes the home videos
and everybody [ __ ] gets around
you know the tv and they're all tearing
up oh what a sentimental little sad
thing you made
we're crying because we're so happy
right nobody trashes them
calls them a little sensitive little
[ __ ] something homophobic like it would
really go down no everybody is tolerant
of this [ __ ] and his little uh
what was that movie with the chick with
the rose petals coming down on her tits
right remember that and the kids filming
the trash and nobody understood a man
that's who he should have been
you know
getting shot in the garage whatever the
[ __ ] happened something happened in the
garage didn't somebody get shot
you know
i thought it was a little on the nose
that the hard-ass guy
across the street was gay
you know
that whole thing that people who hate
gay people it's secretly secretly
because they're gay
you know what i mean
i'm not saying that doesn't happen but i
mean people who hate the al-qaeda is
that because they're secretly the
al-qaeda
well metaphorically speaking maybe oh
who gives a [ __ ] i don't need to see the
commercial anymore that's all i'm saying
is that all you say no i think it is
i think that's what i'm saying you want
to start an argument and ruin my [ __ ]
holiday week
i just told you [ __ ] i'm in a good mood
what more do i have to do
um
with holidays
with the holidays
comes family members
dude um
the reason why this podcast is extra
late is one because i'm on a vacation
and i don't give a [ __ ]
you know
i don't give a [ __ ] all right
i'm trying to work but it's a half day
for me too just like if you if your
[ __ ] boss made you come in today
to do the end of the year spreadsheets
whatever the hell you got to do right
and all you're hearing is [ __ ] uh
bowl game music in your head i
understand you that's where that's where
i'm at
okay so why don't i do a little longer
podcast this week and help you limp
through your [ __ ] half day
you know
you're the only poor bastard that's in
the office right now
you know
the boss trying to make you feel like
you're special i'll tell you i only
brought in my best employees today
and you six
are at the top of the list of people
that i knew
were in debt
just far enough and were raised just
well enough to not tell me to go [ __ ]
myself so that's why i asked you six
i was wrong about the other two
um
so anyways um i couldn't do the podcast
today because i have uh you know
some relatives over here crashing with
me and i don't have a podcast studio
except for the all things comedy podcast
studio but i only use that
when i interview people
um like dave keckner fifa missed that
one um other than that i just do it my
[ __ ] house so all my shits downstairs
you know one of my cousins is asleep
downstairs i get the [ __ ] there i don't
want to wake him up or whatever so uh
i'm also doing my end of the year [ __ ]
where i have to get all my paperwork
together
you know to make sure all
all the uh eyes are dotted all the t's
across to make sure if ever there's a
knock on the door from those [ __ ] who
are on the legal side of stealing come
up to me and say oh do you have your
paperwork
so we can take this money from you and
then do whatever the [ __ ] we want with
it
you know
so um i've been avoiding doing this
but over the years the paperwork has
just gotten too big and i went down
that's what i did this morning
okay during my vacation i drove down to
staples
and i bought a file cabinet
and i got to tell you it was uh
if you too wasn't playing
over the speakers and thank god for you
too by the way that somehow something of
that level of quality can actually seep
into
the uh the whatever the the play
selection at a [ __ ] office max
you know it's brilliant
but they can still be that uplifting yet
still be pop and still be played in a
department store
you know that was the only thing keeping
me going because of [ __ ] soul
crushing i don't know what it is about
buying a file cabinet and i don't want
to hear any [ __ ] first world problems
you know the amount of [ __ ] people
who've never left the first world and
don't even know anything about the
[ __ ] third world other than what the
[ __ ] they see on tv which is basically
some [ __ ] reporter with a army helmet
on
stand and we're trying to get
we're trying to get more bamboo and have
a [ __ ] well built i mean what do you
know about the third world before you
tell me that before you lean over your
potato skins and a [ __ ] applebee's
you know and act like you're
appreciating your your [ __ ] lot in
life you're eating potato skins
okay they should be doing that in the
third world if they have nothing to live
for stick that down your throat and have
a [ __ ] heart attack here you are
living in the [ __ ] best goddamn
situation you can possibly be in and
what are you doing huh you're draining
the oil out of your ass
[Laughter]
sorry
so i go there
um and a lot of people too who i think
even use that expression first world
problem they don't even know what it
means they just heard enough people say
it and then they get it just oh you kind
of say it during this part of a
conversation i do that all the time i
have all kinds of words in the english
language that i could not give you a
definition of but i could use perfectly
in a sentence because i heard enough
other people doing it you know it's like
all those people who can do michael
jackson's [ __ ] leg kick with the
loafer
you know can they go beyond that no but
they can do that part
they've seen that part yeah
they've seen that enough
right
okay but if you notice when they walk
down the street none of the [ __ ]
sidewalks lighten up and that's what
that's my point if you can't do the
[ __ ] math on that then i can't help
you
um so i go into this staples
and uh it was a good youtube song
it wasn't one of their douchey ones like
beautiful day
then all of a sudden bono starts
screaming at me what a beautiful day it
is it's like yeah but it was a beautiful
day until you started [ __ ] screaming
at me
why don't you tell the edge to take it
down
tell larry to get off the [ __ ] crash
symbol maybe ride on a [ __ ] high hit
maybe take out the brushes you know
um anyway so i walk in there
and these are my selections
there's either uh
the staples
okay first of all you have the company
that all we do is we make file cabinets
all right and they have this [ __ ]
band-aid beige
four-drawer [ __ ] file cabinet
you know
i just looked at it and i might you know
i just
i just just felt something in my chest
just gave way
you know
i think it was hope
some form of hope i don't know
something like say i lived 80 years
you know i would have lived 80 years and
a half a day if i didn't do what i did
this morning you know what i mean i
really and i believe that [ __ ] too
i think anytime you're doing something
in life that you don't want to be doing
i think that adds up
in the other end
you know you would have been 90 but in
the end of your life you die at 82.
because if you add up all those [ __ ]
moments of going to staples
you know we need batteries and standing
in line at the [ __ ] drugstore with
the skeleton shift
you know and there's nobody there to
[ __ ] unlock the goddamn thing to get
you the [ __ ] batteries
you got to wait to the [ __ ] lines
done so the chick behind the register
come on all of that [ __ ] ends up adding
up to like eight and a half years
of your life and that's just trying to
buy [ __ ]
you know forget about if you're uh
living with the wrong person
i'm speaking of which
not to [ __ ]
not to air the dirty laundry of my
neighborhood but i gotta tell you
something
all my neighbors i i've lucked out
[ __ ] great people but i got to have
like three three doors
up the [ __ ] street
is this older couple
i don't know how old they are
they sound like they've been together
forever
but they the way the the energy they
have when they scream at each other i
still think they're in their 50s
you know
like they got one more big contract
they're going to ask for four years
you know life's only going to give them
three and then they're gonna [ __ ]
they're gonna move to seattle like canal
right
so
when they yell at each other i swear to
god
the the
the i can't even hate
the [ __ ] bile
when they yell at each other like they
are so done with each other
i every time there's a pause in the
argument
like he says [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah i'm like the [ __ ] i can't
even do it
it's like
it's not quite blood curdling scream
and it's not quite just like
maniacal rage it's somewhere between the
two
that the only way you can duplicate it
is if you have that sort of pain in your
heart
and they scream at each other and every
time they pause
when there's that pause i'm just i wince
because i'm waiting to hear the gunshot
you know what i mean
i don't know
and then there's that weird part too
that i it also makes me feel good like
wow i have a great relationship
i mean i know we have a battles i know
i've been a [ __ ] idiot i've done
everything i could to steer it into the
[ __ ] [ __ ] sun
but at the end of the day i come home
with a chocolate chip cookie i do what i
got to do right
so
i mean i didn't know the [ __ ] where the
hell was i was back at staples
so i'm back at staples and i'm looking
at these things so i
and as always they got like one person
at the register and then one other poor
bastard
who's got to cover the whole [ __ ]
floor
so i walk up there and i'm like looking
around
there's nobody to help me
all they have is the [ __ ] on the floor i
don't there's no box i can grab it's in
the back
so i just walk up and i say to the lady
at the register because i see there's a
guy with a two-wheeler helping somebody
else with something heavy
and i
set it over his shoulder i was talking
to the [ __ ] lady behind the register
but he didn't realize that i go um is
anybody who can help me
uh get a file cabinet and without
turning around he goes i will help you
sir when i'm done helping this customer
so
i immediately get it
the old me would have been like hey
first of all i wasn't talking to you and
i understand that you can't do two
things at once all right but i didn't i
understood the whole [ __ ] thing
this had nothing to do with him had
nothing to do with me i guess i had to
do with me or i could have stepped more
to the side
you know
i had more of a uh a straight-up
conversation with the registered lady
but uh i knew what's going on this was
this this had this came from corporate
they were running as few [ __ ] people
as possible
this guy was having to do way too
[ __ ] much for what he was getting
paid for so that caused him to come at
me the way he was coming at me and i was
coming at them the way i was coming at
them because i couldn't get any [ __ ]
help and in the end
the real [ __ ] that created it are
sitting on their christmas yacht
so
i let it go i just laughed or whatever
and he came back and i made a joke about
how you know he ought to have another
five guys out there helping him
um which relax the situation so now here
we are the two of us him having to cover
way too much square footage
you know like a five on three in hockey
except it's the staples version of it
you know maybe like more like a five on
two if that was possible
so and there i am standing there trying
to pick out which file cabinet i want
both of us
minutes just just falling off of our
lives
and he got all right so what's
i guess i need this one here i
and i told him i go dude i can't believe
how depressing this is to buy this thing
and he just started laughing
and i go all right so
these look the same why is this one
fifty dollars more
he's like all right that's uh so so
they're known for making file cabinets
they make the file cabinets and that's
just the staples version
so i got all right i start pounding the
file cabinet
you know
listening to the sound hitting either
one of them you know
trying to figure out which one sounds
more solid obviously the guys that
that's all they do their sounds more
solid
staples is trying to undercut them being
such douchebags they put theirs right
next to it they make it the exact same
color for like 50 bucks less now i
should say you know what [ __ ] that file
hit cabinet people
i should just save myself 50 bucks but
that's not how i'm wired
i don't know why
i i said [ __ ] those staples [ __ ] like
the file cabinet people actually give a
[ __ ] about me
i don't think they do but they give a
[ __ ] enough to make a [ __ ] higher
quality file cabinet so i go with that
one
and uh
i don't know we wheel the [ __ ] thing
out i'm sitting there going can this fit
in a prius i have a truck i didn't
realize i was gonna buy this thing i was
hoping i was gonna buy something else
and i realized somewhere between
the [ __ ] u2 song and the [ __ ] boy
band that i had to buy a goddamn file
cabinet
and we're laughing we put the thing in
the back of the car i tried to tip him
he goes no no no no because this is what
i do right the guy we [ __ ] won't even
take the goddamn money
so he leaves and i'm driving this
[ __ ] thing home
you know
feeling like that dude
in the end of the movie and last
american virgin when this [ __ ] chick
cheats on him with the douche who
knocked him up earlier and he's driving
away in the purple [ __ ] station wagon
with the tear coming down his eye that's
what i feel like
so i was like how can i turn this [ __ ]
around
so anyways i get back to the house the
relatives are still [ __ ] sleeping i
got the file cabinet back of the prius
i'm an old man i got a bad back
you know but i got that german irish
blood i'm like i'm i'll [ __ ] do it
myself
i'll put it over my head i'll open the
gate with my foot and i'll uh slip
another disc and i was fine like you
know what [ __ ] this
i'll wait till my cousin gets up that's
all they say in the western mass
sometimes my cousin
um
i don't know if it's western mass i
don't know where the [ __ ] i heard that
in my travels uh
i decided i was gonna [ __ ] leave it
there
so i sat down and put on the tv and lo
and behold lo and [ __ ] behold what's
on television as i put it on my favorite
goddamn show
all right fast and loud the gas monkey
garage guys so i'm sitting there
watching them and everything they got to
customize it and all that type of [ __ ]
and you know what
i'm thinking about my stupid file
cabinet how [ __ ] cool their lives are
their motorcycles and their awesome cars
and how they make everything look
[ __ ] cool and i was like you know
what
why don't i have somebody [ __ ] paint
this goddamn file cabinet
i live in los angeles california
we're all hot riding hot rodding
allegedly started or they do the best
interiors out here they do all these
[ __ ] great paint jobs why don't i get
somebody it's [ __ ]
soul-crushing band-aid light brown
it's even lighter than that throw a
little bit of cream in there just for
you lactose intolerant people to make
everybody puke on this podcast that's
what it looks like so here's my question
for you does anybody know anybody in the
los angeles area or i could bring a file
cabinet over there and they could
paint it a color
that's gonna that's gonna make me happy
and i don't i don't even need no i don't
need some [ __ ] design just put maybe
just
mmp on the side of it just something
[ __ ] cool so i can look at it
and and not just like i mean just have
my shoulders slumped down like
like that [ __ ] quarterback for the
cowboys when he threw that last
interception against the eagles man
jesus christ are the cowboy fans paying
enough
for their five [ __ ] super bowls
good lord
a buddy of mine texted me god's team
before before the uh
before the game started and uh i don't
know what you guys did to him
you know we were you guys too arrogant
after your last super bowl win
what did you do
you take out your 10 gallon hat take a
[ __ ] in it and [ __ ]
put it over a steelers fan's head or
something i don't know what the [ __ ] you
did but jesus christ
um
i i've you know i i was a cowboys fan uh
right up until they fired tom landry in
texture tech ram left then they fired
tom landry
and it went from this
stoic we do things the right way over
here
tahiha
how about them cowboys hey wait it just
got too [ __ ]
cartoony for me
um
even though i like all i like everybody
on that team um and i think i rooted for
him in all the super bowls didn't i
played the bills twice
then they played the steelers yeah i had
to root for him against the steelers
because i lost money first [ __ ] super
bowl i bet
was the 78 game
arguably the greatest a massive talent
ever
when the cowboys played the steelers and
lost to him i lost 75 cents which was a
lot of [ __ ] money to me in the fourth
grade
it was you know
that was a hot lunch back then
[Laughter]
so anyway so here's the deal
if you guys know anybody out here that
would do it would take it off if you
know an up-and-coming painter or
something like that i have some
ideas i definitely have some ideas you
know uh of some [ __ ] i want done
and i would probably be great
if i could give you a [ __ ]
just hit me up on twitter or hit me up
on facebook
just send me a message or something like
that um
i don't know turn this [ __ ] thing
into something i want to look at
i'll pay you top dollar i don't give a
[ __ ]
just i have to have a file cabinet
all right that's the end i don't know
what else to do with all the papers i'm
supposed to pick keep for these [ __ ]
goddamn people running [ __ ] i just can't
look at this [ __ ] thing anymore
all right i've i even left it in the box
um
all right what else
oh speaking of that
[ __ ] laying on the floor
um
bring this over here somebody sent me
this uh
well how far into the podcast are we
20 minutes in jesus christ bill 20
minutes you bitching about a file
cabinet you [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
let's uh let's let's get the reeds on we
only got two this week people
two very special ones all right number
one out of the gate
dollar shave club
all right for a couple of for a couple
of bucks a month geez right out of the
gate that's like a false start let's do
that again
dollar shave club everyone for a couple
of bucks a month
uh dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door not
only does it save you a ton of cash it
saves you from trudging your sorry ass
down to the drugstore for a pack of
blades all right i've talked to this
before i always go there late at night
they'll have one person working on the
floor they're behind the register i
gotta wait till they get through the
line to go over and unlock the goddamn
things like they're made out of gold
um you don't have to deal with that
anymore because now with dollar shave
club for just a couple of bucks a month
amazing quality razor blades are
delivered right to your door that's
right that is correct thumbs up no more
wasting time and no more getting hit up
for 20 bucks every time you buy raises
everybody here is getting that dollar
shave club blades and you should too and
here's a genius idea try replacing your
old shaving cream with dr cave easy
shave butter from dollarshaveclub.com
trust me your face will thank you later
clothes oh sorry i wasn't supposed to
read that here's the big close everybody
don't waste time at the drugstore behind
the lady paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash blur
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low in your bank account
balance high shave time shave money go
go to dollarshaveclub.com
i literally had to close one of my eyes
to get through that without [ __ ] up
anymore
um legalzoom
some things like starting a business or
protecting your family
with a will aren't like yeah i just
can't i just i went blank in the middle
of that
there's too many words with w's all
right start over again
legalzoom
some things like starting a business or
protecting your family with a will
aren't like your others new other new
year's resolutions
you can't afford to blow them off
i can't [ __ ] suck at this
[ __ ] all right number three take three
on two ready break legal zoom some
things like starting a business or
protecting your family with the will
aren't like your others knew you this is
written so [ __ ] difficult
legalzoom everyone some things like
starting a business or protecting your
family with a will aren't like your
other new year's resolutions
you can't afford to blow them off
instead of less snacking and more
exercise put them at the top of your
list
legalzoom helps you incorporate or form
an llc with their simple questionnaire
starting at just ninety nine dollars
over one million entrepreneurs have done
it and ninety percent of customers
recommend legalzoom to friends and
family you can also create a will
starting at just 69 bucks or even a
living trust quickly and easily get
peace of mind and protection no surprise
fees no hassles and no headaches
legalzoom step-by-step process was
created by a team of experts in law and
technology legalzoom is not a law firm
but you can but can connect you with a
third-party attorney and provide you
with self-help services from wills to
business formations trademarks powers of
attorneys and more go to legalzoom.com
for even more savings type in bur
b-u-r-r into the referral box at the
checkout
don't put off things you need to do go
to legalzoom.com now and use discount
code burr that's legalzoom.com discount
code burr
jesus
[ __ ] greg normand on that one
um
on sunday
all right what am i talking about now uh
what did i do this weekend well i did
some sets around town
getting ready for my uh bucket list show
at the will turn theater
and i got some new ones for you sons of
[ __ ]
oh do i got some new ones i was out last
night
i went down to the comedy store and i
got to run my set twice because they're
awesome they got like two three shows
going at all times down at the wonderful
comedy store and they put me up twice
and i had a great time
and
i was doing that all weekend i did take
saturday night off because i wanted to
watch that ufc ufc
championship in the world um ufc 168
anderson silver versus that other guy i
still don't know his name i haven't even
taken the time to learn his [ __ ] name
because i was so convinced
that you know that he lost the first one
just because he was [ __ ] around
and i should know the champ's name here
let me look this up
anderson silva
verse
chris weidman
i hope i'm saying that right weedman
weidman i'm sorry
all right
i thought the writing was on the wall
because
uh matt that tara sarah was in his camp
and i'm like oh man that's like when he
he knocked out uh george st pierre
and everyone was going oh george didn't
[ __ ] train and yada yada yada and
then then uh
matt the terracera was going uh let him
eat him drink wine or whatever i thought
it was hilarious but he ended up coming
back and beating him
um you know i'm not trashing obviously
not sarah at all but i'm just saying so
i just thought that maybe this was going
to happen again because the first time
they had the fight
like i've watched roy jones jr like uh
make fun of people or clown them as the
youth says i never seen it done at the
level of that first fight it was like
[ __ ] ridiculous
um
and he ended up making a stupid face
the guy punched him and knocked him out
so it's like all right you know he's
coming in this time and he's just he's
going to handle his business right as
the youth says how do i get all this
[ __ ] hip-hop [ __ ] in my i don't know
i don't even listen to this stuff
um
so anyways
maybe because it's ruled the charts for
15 years bill and it is mainstream maybe
you heard it in staples you read [ __ ]
um so anyway so i get this fight because
i want to see the rematch
to see if this chris uh weedman a
weidman guy is for real crushes it kills
me that i don't know his [ __ ]
that i'm not pronouncing his name
correctly um
but anyways i wanted to see that and
then also i wanted to watch that uh
that ronda rousey uh mishnah tate fight
because me and the lovely nia were
watching the ufc uh fight club [ __ ]
show the whole season
and i gotta tell you man it was an
unbelievable night unbelievable
unbelievable night of fights if you
haven't ordered it yet it's totally
worth the money
and i had a bunch of people come over
and uh we watched the fight
and i'm not there's no spoil all right
spoiler alert if you i don't know if
you're living under a [ __ ] rock you
weren't paying attention uh anderson
silva [ __ ] snapped his goddamn leg
oh the second time this year i've seen
it the kid on louisville and now that
it's just
it was not uh it was not pretty but i
got to tell you that that the other dude
chris was was
was winning the fight at that point
you know what i want to i want to ask
joe rogan i got to call in his podcast
because he said something during that
fight
that i thought was uh really interesting
where he said once you get knocked out
you know you're never the same as far as
your ability
to
i guess take a punch like that again
like i i don't i didn't quite understand
it because it's not like you lose brain
fluid
it's still sitting in the same amount of
fluid but maybe you
i don't know what's going on so i wanted
to ask him about that because i found
that really fascinating because i
remember roy jones jr
no one could ever touch him and then he
finally got knocked out and after he got
knocked out it seemed easier
with each time to knock him out and
people were trying to say oh you know uh
the the the air of invincibility is gone
and i didn't think that i just it seemed
like
he something there was something
different about him i don't know
i found that really interesting so
next time i run into him i'm definitely
going to ask him about it i thought i
had a lot to say about that
that ufc [ __ ] i guess i didn't i always
just get blown away how [ __ ] tough
those guys are
you know like i'll tell you one thing
that that guy who came in the guy the
lumberjack guy
who was really in bad shape for an
ultimate fighter i we were sitting there
watching going this guy has the [ __ ]
torso of like a regional manager if he
didn't have that i will murder your
whole family and then sit down and eat
soup afterwards look on his face
one of the most terrifying looks i've
ever seen he came in
like not like i'm gonna beat you he's
like i'm gonna like i was he was gonna
kill the other guy
so they end up having their fight
and uh
oh [ __ ] uh
awful torso takes a knee to the head
drops to his legs grabs the other guys
drops to his knees grabs the other guy's
legs and this guy reigns
like
i don't know four elbows and he must
have been using the perfect technique
because when they showed it in slow
motion it was almost like this beginning
of a break dance move it was very uh uh
fluid the way he was doing it with uh
with a little bit of flair
you know it wasn't like he was just
bringing it up like how it was
a jerk off like me like
it was like it was like this aerodynamic
i don't know what he was doing
it looked [ __ ] great he should have a
little pinky out
it was
like six of the classiest [ __ ] elbows
to the side of the head i've ever seen
and that was the end of that lumberjack
and any murderous thoughts he ever had
that why is my voice cracking um
i don't know i always like seeing that i
love seeing when a guy goes into the
octagon and i just see the look on his
face and i feel whatever manhood i even
possess
just drain out of me and just see the
other guy just across the ring like oh
that's a tough look you got there well
guys we're guys with gage and then it's
[ __ ] over
you know then you wish you could do some
something like that you know maybe
there's some terrorists on a flight and
then you land the plane
and they want to give you the key to the
city but you don't show up because
you're too [ __ ] cool for it anybody
else just go on those long fantasies
like that i do it i do it all the time
you know what i won't apologize for it i
like living in my own little world
between my two years i in my two years i
am a hell of a [ __ ] guy
i'm a war veteran i'm a hero
i know how to [ __ ] well
i'm good at math it's just it's endless
um
[Laughter]
anybody watching any of the nfl football
yesterday
um i actually went on a hike yesterday
you know like the half a twinkle toes i
am
and uh went with another buddy of mine
just to make it even uh
more homoerotic
and uh
i don't know i wasn't interested in any
of the earlier [ __ ] games
and plus i've been eating like [ __ ] you
know with the holiday food and
everything so i was like i gotta get out
at least try to walk around a little bit
so
we decided we're gonna go on this hike
and uh
we just kept extending it and extending
it and extending it and i knew i was
going to pay the price for it long story
short we got [ __ ] lost
we tried to cut down this one ridge
and it just ended up getting so [ __ ]
steep like i was just like if one of us
falls
um i'm not saying we're we're we're
gonna die from the fall but we're gonna
die from laying there for four days
until coyotes finally find us and like
just pick us apart
you know
as we try if we we're just laying on our
backs and you know making those noises
you make
as you're trying to fight off jackals
with a stick
you know
um i would stab myself with a stick
personally
i'd always take the coward way up
not gonna feel that wild animal's breath
up against my earlobes
just trying to get a better [ __ ] lock
on my neck i don't i don't need that
i don't need that um oh speaking of some
reason that made me feel think of ronda
rousey how she just [ __ ] gradually
got the armbar going there
um
people flipped out when she didn't shake
hands afterwards
they were booing the [ __ ] out of her i
thought it was a great fight i'm all
right if they don't shake hands
afterwards
hey how about after you [ __ ] break
their arm you show a little bit of class
and shake the [ __ ] arm that you
didn't break
who gives a [ __ ] you know i liked it i
enjoyed it i liked that she didn't shake
the heads
what was that what did that teach the
kids
what does that teach them you know when
they're done punching their friend in
the face and then [ __ ] snapping their
arm if they don't get up and shake their
[ __ ]
quivering hand
i liked it i enjoyed it oh the lovely
nia everybody she was going shush i have
things to do look at you with your fancy
shoes
that's it
you look great thank you
all right
um
anyways the [ __ ] was i talking about
yeah i enjoyed it i didn't have a
problem that she didn't [ __ ] uh
shake her hand but i like both fighters
and i wish him well oh look at me
being a goddamn diplomat here
um
anyways what the [ __ ] was i just talking
about oh i was talking about uh nfl
football
oh no the hike that's right so we ended
up getting lost went 20 minutes in the
wrong direction so those of you who are
halfway decent at meth that's a 40
minute [ __ ] mistake and uh
we were just laughing by the end ended
up being a four hour hike
my buddy's like one of these dudes who's
like really into technology
so with every hike he has something else
you know i got an app on my phone that
will tell us how far we went
it starts with that and then next i i
got a bracelet
that's uh measuring all the calories i'm
burning
give you some sort of indicate it's like
give us a [ __ ]
he gives a [ __ ] he's into he's into that
[ __ ]
so um
i think uh the hike ended up being like
11 miles we like walked half a marathon
and the running joke was i was gonna be
back in time for the one o'clock kickoff
one o'clock out here for the pats game
and with every mistake we made i just
kept saying like
am i gonna have to have nia tape the
[ __ ] game
we ran out of water
and um
but you know we were nearing up to
civilization there was other hikers
there and that type of [ __ ] but it was
uh
i don't know all i know is i ate like
[ __ ]
when i came back and i still woke up
today with a flatter stomach than i had
yesterday that is how far we hiked and
you know what people that's the end of
my mediocre hiking story
we're taking callers does anybody else
have a mediocre and hiking [ __ ] story
um all right let's get to some questions
for this week i didn't talk about the
patriots game um [ __ ] great game
could not finish him off um should have
lost the game
if the bills didn't
i don't know
i don't know what they were doing i
actually tweeted
in the the end of the third quarter
actually tweeted did the bills bet the
patriots
and i got to tell you the amount of
people who thought who read that is did
the bills beat the patriots and i got
all these people why don't you just look
it up instead of tweeting about it you
dumb [ __ ]
so i get i got to write back to a bunch
of people going
bet not beat
i didn't say anything mean i didn't
trash them at all i just corrected them
because i knew that that would hurt more
and you know me
you know me from twitter's to fatties
i'm all about shaming
because that's how i was brought up
um patriots bills everybody uh
i don't know what to say about the game
other than it [ __ ] rained i'm happy
that we won
another unbelievably successful season
for the patriots i think tom brady had
his arguably his best season
just considering what the [ __ ] he was
working with
i let the defense
rose to the occasion but having said all
of that i will be surprised if we win
more than one playoff game and i won't
be surprised if we're one and done
just because uh
well the afc is kind of weak but i don't
know it's just it's different it's
different when it comes to january so
you probably got to be asking yourself
well then who you picking bill you
staying with the [ __ ] dirty birds out
there the seahawks i guess dirty birds
of the falcons yeah i think it's the
seahawks to
lose it's huge that they got the home
field
because for some reason i don't know why
they don't quite play as well on the
road but they still ended up at what
13-3 i definitely think it that it's
theirs to lose
um
i don't know i was in europe for [ __ ]
three weeks so i missed a lot of the
football i can't really even talk
intelligently about who
i think can beat them
you know my buddies saying the 49ers
that's always a good pick to pick a
division rival because they know each
other so well
uh but i definitely think it's theirs to
lose and it would be nice to see them
finally win the super bowl and give
their fans something
to actually be loud about
you know i know i've trashed a lot of
the seattle fans for that dumb record
but i you know i didn't know it just
annoyed me
that
your owner [ __ ] you so bad on those
premium beers and you guys busted him
for it
and then immediately
he just gets back in your good graces by
just stroking your [ __ ] balls taint
and [ __ ] with this loudest fan's
horseshit
how much money did he make off of that
[ __ ] beer [ __ ] you guys over as
you sat there screaming your [ __ ]
heads off
you know that's all it takes a couple of
trinkets a little placket on the wall
and everybody goes actually somebody
said tonight that last night i was
talking to this other comic and he was
telling me how he likes the pope you
know i like the pope i like this guy he
says he's cool with atheists you know
you don't mind if gay people get married
it's like that's because they're
hemorrhaging cash
in the [ __ ] west in the northern
hemisphere it's a business
they're only adding people down in south
america but as far as up here they're
[ __ ] they're losing people day by day
so they have to adjust their message
the same way when bp was involved in
that horrific oil spill all of a sudden
now their logo is painted in the color
of grass and corn or sunlight hey man
it's green they care about the
environment man that's that's
that's what the seahawks owner did
he was doing that boss hog [ __ ] and you
guys caught him or somebody caught him
i got to give you the guys the link to
that video they had the thing right they
had the tall beer the premium [ __ ]
beer the uh costs more and then they had
the short fat one
and somebody finally sucked down a short
fat one and then poured the tall one
into the short fat one as the exact same
amount of ounces they didn't have the
decency to make it two ounces more so it
kind of spilled over and that would have
ended it they were so [ __ ] cheap
i'm getting halfway through this and i'm
forgetting if there actually was a
seahawks owner but i'm too i'm in too
deep now i just got to go with the lie
maybe it's the truth that's what they
did
so what does he do he starts getting
[ __ ] former celebrities
people from top gun to come up there and
ring that bell to get the 12th man thing
going
he just stroked your [ __ ] balls
and you bought into it he's not your
friend
all right i haven't said all that i hope
you guys win a championship because i
like the seahawks way back uh
when they had jim zorn and steve largent
david craig kirk warner i like those
teams
um i actually i'm not being a douche
here i don't mind your new you you're
one of the few teams that had a nice
uniform and actually
was sort of a lateral move
but i like the older ones man i like
that silver helmet i thought it was
[ __ ] cool
um
all right enough with my half-assed
half-assed [ __ ] nfl talk i am going
to the pro bowl again this year people
and this time i'm hoping i'm going to
make it
um last year i ended up getting some
acting work but it was uh was actually
oh i never told you guys this story it's
my it was the final episode i got to do
on breaking bad
and i won't ruin it because i know
people are watching
the thing but it's basically it's a
scene
in the well you know what it is because
you'll watch the last half of the fifth
episode and you'll see the last one i'm
in that scene where i'm sitting in the
car with those two other characters
um
that was
i had a gig saturday night
in honolulu
um
and then the next day me and jayla had
rose bowl legend
and one of the uh comedians on the show
tomorrow night at the wilter
um
we did the show and then the next day we
were gonna go to the pro bowl
and uh
i don't know this is a running joke in
show business that if you want to book
acting work you know book some sort of
vacation book some sort of fun because
if you're sitting there watching the
phone like you will not work for 10
years but if you go you know what [ __ ]
this
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i
don't know i'm gonna go on a [ __ ]
vacation i don't know what money you'd
go with if you weren't getting acting
work but whatever you just plan
something
hey me my boys are gonna go to this game
immediately you're getting acting work
so it's kind of it's kind of a good
thing but uh
um
so anyways i had i did the gig and then
i literally had to fly
back to la the very next day and then
from la
to uh albuquerque new mexico and then we
were the first one out of the gate
that's why i couldn't go to the game i
remember that we shot that scene at like
uh
god what was it i think the call time
was like five in the morning
five in the morning and i think we
started shooting at six
and we were done by like 6 30. like
that was the thing about when you did
that show was that everybody was so
goddamn good
um
they just had the coverage they had the
dialogue
they just had it down
and uh
i don't know they made you look great so
all i did was just make sure i always
knew my lines know your [ __ ] lines
say what they wrote hit your mark and
they're gonna make you look great and uh
the other two guys were regulars so they
were
and awesome so they knew what the [ __ ]
they were doing so we were in and out of
there and like
in and out of there in like 30 minutes
oh back to back mediocre story i'm
[ __ ] crushing it just slapping
signals to the opposite field hitting
for average here people
um
anyways
all right so
let's let's go here all right let's
let's read some of the letters
some of the letters how come there's not
a new year song i feel like singing this
week and then all there is
is that awful one
awful [ __ ] one
what is that how's it he's a jolly good
fellow right isn't that how it goes
should all the quaintage be forgotten
never brought to mind i never understood
what that meant
i don't know what all anxiety means
just a sad
[ __ ] grape's a wrath kind of [ __ ]
i just you know i just feel like i'm in
the dust bowl when i sing that [ __ ]
song it's just
it's not a happy song
oh jesus bill
jesus christ who pissed in your cheerios
um all right newsletter hey bill do you
have a newsletter to let me know when
you'll be live in the south again
um i announce them on this podcast and i
i announce it uh
via twitter and facebook or whatever
that's basically how i do it speaking of
which
we have almost got all the dates for the
canadian tour lined up
and i'll let you know i'm going to some
[ __ ] places that uh i never thought
i'd go so it's not just the hockey
cities i'm also going to other ones just
to get your canadian hopes up that
you're not gonna have to drive over to
another province
um
i probably shouldn't have done that but
uh there's definitely some uh
some pretty [ __ ]
it's gonna be fun it's gonna be fun and
i'm bringing my hockey stuff up there
i'm going to figure out where there's a
pond hockey game or some place where i
can play and i want to go up there and
get embarrassed i want you people up
there in canada to show me
once and for all that it is in fact your
game
okay
um i don't know i'm going to figure out
that i want to do that i want to get
drunk and and do some curling
and i i feel like my time update will be
uh complete
okay
i want to do that
and i want you to help me do that so
next week within the week i'm going to
announce the dates for the canadian tour
and um
at least the cities
and then i don't the reason why i don't
do it is because then people go is there
a link and then there's not a link well
when is there going to be a link i just
like to [ __ ] put it out there when i
have all the information like hey i'm
coming to canada i can tell you this it
is going to be in march all right there
you go
all right here we go okay friends
cheating wife
hey there billy badass
uh longtime fan love your comedy thank
you very much uh i'm currently in the
air force
and one of my co-workers wife is a total
[ __ ]
now wait a minute let's see what she's
done here my wife and his wife friends
oh wait my wife and his wife's friend
are friends so she shares a lot of
details with her she's sleeping with
numerous guys on base and a couple of
guys in our work section oh no
and she's telling your wife about it
what she wants to get caught uh the
messed up thing is that he knows all the
guys
that she's messing around with
in the past my co-worker was a real dog
but has cleaned up his act since getting
married he did all his dirt before
marriage or before marriage but she sees
this is a payback oh
oh well what the [ __ ]
then they never should have gotten
married
i mean i'm not going to judge anybody in
the story you know there but for the
grace of god go why i was a piece of
[ __ ]
you know
but they they shouldn't have got married
he did all his dirt before marriage but
sees this as payback and even told my
wife
that she only married him for the
benefits
yeah well what are you gonna do this
thing was uh
this was
built in sand with some toxic waste in
it it's so crazy that one of the married
guys she's sleeping with sat at the
table the same table with us during our
annual christmas party
that's not the bad part they have two
children together
every time we deploy for six months she
brings the guys to their house
wow
dragging the kids into it
all right she went jordan on that
she just took the [ __ ]
she she changed the game there
i'm leaving this base soon and i feel
that i should say something
if not directly maybe indirectly to help
him figure it out
himself
what do you what do you think maybe you
think
maybe you think about making us stop in
guam
oh you went the other way okay uh i'll
be there for the next three months and i
know that you'd kill with the military
community dude i'd [ __ ] go to guam
isn't that from the spanish-american war
there
um
ah jesus christ so obviously he was
[ __ ] around before they got married
and now oh now he's stopped
this is a this is a friend of yours
uh
i'm currently air force and one it's my
co-worker's wife
so he's a co-worker
all right well listen i think this is up
to you if you want to get involved in
this thing um
i don't know how about an anonymous
letter nah i don't do that because then
he's trying to think who knows and who
doesn't know
i don't know dude i don't know how to
cross that one
i don't know how to cross that one
um
tell them
i don't look at you know what it's hard
to have sympathy for them i mean you
can't sit there and uh
do that to somebody and think they're
not gonna do it back to you
i've learned all the lessons in this
[ __ ] story in my horrific [ __ ]
single life so uh
i you know so all right how do i tell
this one
i knew a
guy i know a bloke who knows a bloke who
knows a bloke
that uh
how do i say this he was going to get
married to this girl and he knew that
she was [ __ ] around on him and he
went and told the dude and the dude
didn't believe him and then got mad at
him and then stopped being friends with
him and then he went on and had two kids
and she continued to [ __ ] around and ten
years later he's paying alimony and
child support
so um it all depends on your peace of
mind i mean this guy isn't a friend of
yours what the [ __ ] just say like look
dude we're not friends i'm leaving i i
don't have a dog in this fight i just
feel like you should know i guess that
that's what i would do
um you should do it you should do it for
the [ __ ] kids
good lord good lord good lord those kids
are going to be [ __ ] up they're
already [ __ ] up it's over
it's over
jesus christ
if they were dogs they'd put them all
down on the street they're all they all
got rabies at this point
terrible terrible terrible things
terrible things are done
jesus christ that was a horrible [ __ ]
story
uh burst stock
whatever that means bergenstock
um long time billy freedom trail
long time fan i was wondering to myself
the other day how much longer until we
get a billboard event some type of
festival an event where you're the ring
master and master of ceremonies you
could host pie eating contests i'd make
the [ __ ] pies
uh judge a beauty pageant
actually a pie eating contest they don't
really make good pies do they they just
sort of [ __ ] you just eat out the
filling
um judge a beauty pageant and cut a
ribbon with a novelty sized pair of
scissors dude if i could judge a pig too
i would do this you set it up i'll do it
vendors will sell turkey legs cotton
candy and fried dough babies will get
their faces painted
uh and while you're not hosting an event
you'll be walking around the grounds in
a seersucker soup dude i'm [ __ ] in
you'll probably say something about not
many people coming out for it that's not
true a few thousand people would come
out
uh liz walker will cover it on the six
o'clock news and the following year
there'll be ten thousand people will fly
in from lots of places if they get
enough notice don't bother explaining
why this is a bad idea every one of your
listeners is adding up their vacation
days dude this is [ __ ] you know what
i don't know if i want to host it but i
want to go to it
i want to go there with israel i want to
go to something with this [ __ ] a
prize pig
that's what people are fighting for
i would do that in a second sir
you set it up
you set it up and i would change it i
would bring in uh
what else would i have
you need some sort of music
you know i bring more in like street
performers
i know a couple of them from back in the
day in my uh when i was living in new
york
there was a couple of guys that i knew
that were [ __ ] great i actually did a
comedy show and i had one of them come
down and perform
and uh he crushed it
i'd add that element to it so what you
do is this is what you do you have a
little backwood [ __ ] going on you do it
in the backwoods so all the backwoods
people show up but then you know what
about the people who live in the
backwoods in there but they're into [ __ ]
beyond the backwoods that's when you
bring in the street performers from new
york right so people think that even
though it's down home it's also a little
dope as the the kids used to say that
are now older than me
um
i would do something like that
i any of that [ __ ] that's considered
[ __ ] uh
i don't know what it's considered it's
looked down upon by a lot of people out
here
in hollywood you know
who think that you know those that's all
flyover state stuff and that they're cut
above because they write jokes for four
camera shoots sitcoms
um with wacky next door neighbors
um i like all that [ __ ] yeah
do it set it up
you get the ball rolling i'll [ __ ] do
it throw in some [ __ ] some sort of
car show a prize pig
right
there's got to be some sort of blue
ribbon one for a farm animal i already
know there's like a zillion of these
things just tell me where to go i want
to go to one of these things
do i get to shoot a [ __ ] gun hey by
the way i just saw um somebody
recommended this last night i just
watched uh
bobcat go quick bobcat goldwath
can't even talk today yeah i made this
movie called god bless america
uh
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say that
it's a dark comedy
uh
it's on netflix check it out
i'm still working my way through the
first season of the killing just giving
these people all free [ __ ] uh
what do you call it shout outs here
you know i do this because then you guys
go oh you should check this out you
should check this out
um you know actually somebody told me a
book i should order and i ordered the
[ __ ] thing and i never never showed
up
i order [ __ ] and it doesn't show up i i
think i don't hit the uh complete the
deal button
but there's no store to go to
it's [ __ ] genius
i don't know where is amazon.com based
out of
where is that store
does that information exist we're in
dubai
there's no taxes everything's free this
is wonderful oprah turn your [ __ ]
head to the left and see the tent city
on the horizon
all right
yeah i would do that
i would do that i would go to a rodeo
i'd do any of that [ __ ] all right
girlfriend hates you
well she should
uh dear burbank read slowly buddy i know
you can do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
he wrote it in all capital letters too
ah yeah ball busting [ __ ] that was a
funny one it's not 201 is it holy [ __ ]
where did the day go
um all right
i travel all over the country as you do
except i don't do it to make people
laugh i do it so my [ __ ] boss can make
money
anyway
lately i've lately i've been listening
to your podcast in my truck and my
girlfriend can't stand it
she literally hates your guts
simply because you curse what the [ __ ]
uh we end up making deals where we
listen to 10 minutes of [ __ ] beyonce
then 10 minutes of your podcast
god damn it i try to tell her that your
podcasts make my day
and that you are hilarious and generally
a good guy but she totally disagrees can
you tell her a few things
that you do that are nice
uh besides the fact that you make people
laugh for a living which should be
enough no it shouldn't because i get
paid for that uh like charity work
going to the make a wish foundation or
whatever the [ __ ]
let her know you aren't a [ __ ] even
though you are much love from your
canadian friend olay oleo leolae he
wrote um
oh first of all
sir i don't need your girlfriend's
approval i don't give a [ __ ] what she
thinks about me reach for her wrist make
sure she doesn't shut this off
okay
hey lady look what you're doing to the
man in your life right now you're making
him so [ __ ] miserable he enjoys this
podcast he likes that i [ __ ] curse he
likes it
can he just have that
what's worse
in all honesty
the horseshit
that i do on this thing or listen to
somebody say i don't think you're ready
for this jelly
you know
at least i take the piss out of myself
for every podcast i don't walk around
like some arrogant ass
talking about how [ __ ] great i am and
all the [ __ ] i have does she do that i
don't even know she does it i don't
listen to her stuff
um
you know
at least i [ __ ]
i go in one direction i don't come up
with something that's funny and then or
whatever interesting and then say it 50
times in a [ __ ] row do i
if you like it
ring on
or else what you're gonna go suck
another dick if i don't give you
something shiny like this give me
something shiny right now or i'm gonna
go blow somebody else hey lady start
walking
go do that little mime walk like you're
going down a [ __ ] escalator right
down to the dude's dick next to you i
don't give a [ __ ] like this country i
don't respond to threats
okay actually we do but not terrorist
threats
i don't respond to that
okay
listen first of all if i sat here and
listed you don't do nice [ __ ] to tell
people you're doing nice [ __ ] okay isn't
that in the bible heathens pray in
public oh look how holy we are look what
the [ __ ] we're doing if your lady thinks
all i do is bad [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
okay
good lord
what kind of world are you living in
you're driving a truck
and you listen to beyonce
oh my god
i i gotta be honest with you i
i can't watch performers
who don't seem like it any like they
they have this look on their [ __ ]
face that they're just they they can't
even believe how [ __ ] amazing they
are at that point in the crowd i'm just
like well you don't need me
yeah yeah look you know that's like when
these [ __ ] people like they they
score touchdowns or they the athletes
right they [ __ ] dunk balls they do
this [ __ ] and they start thumping their
[ __ ] chest
i can't match that energy
you know
pau gasol dunking a ball or whatever
does a layup and then goes
like you're in 300 you know i'm not
disrespecting their level of athleticism
but you put a ball through a [ __ ]
hoop
jesus christ
punching your own chest
douche chills
all right a lot of that that that type
of [ __ ] i can't get into
you know
like jay-z i really enjoy jay-z but at
some point you're like i get it
you have a lot of stuff
your life is amazing
i could never hope to have a life as
amazing as yours because you are that
amazing
please by all means tell me about your
next big purchase um yeah so dude i
don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
whether you're your woman likes me or
not um if your woman's listening right
now you're a selfish douche
okay
does he sit there going off on beyonce
maybe he does
i don't know maybe the two of you just
need to have a little more respect
for uh you know your playlists
okay
they do make headphones why don't you
put the [ __ ] headphones on
and listen to beyonce why he's driving
the truck he can't have headphones on
that's illegal
and then you could listen to her you
know
making uh financial deals for her
vaginal area
new years everybody here we go dear
billy ball drop
i'm not going to ask you what you're
doing on new year's because i already
know you and your rose bowl crew will be
tap dancing at the wilton over there
i'm going to be there with a girl i'm 50
into
okay well then that affects uh what you
should be buying her that night he goes
she's cool she's hot and i don't have
any major complaints about her i'm also
not in love with her and really can't
see anything beyond hooking up my plan
is to laugh my ass off and see what
happens all right if we hook up that's
great if not no big deal dude you're in
the zone
you're in the zone this is some demon
[ __ ] you don't care if she comes stays
laser praised now you got the attitude
um i don't
i told two friends and they both advised
against hooking up with her
all right well i don't know your friends
and i don't know what their motive is
let's see if you explain this here he
goes i would never let that decide
whether or not i would but the
interesting thing is that they both said
independent of each other that hooking
up with the girl on new year's eve might
give her the wrong impression
and that she's going to be a leech
afterwards oh that's [ __ ] that's just
fear-mongering
that's [ __ ]
what because your finger as the ball
drops all of a sudden you have a
relationship
yeah i had a good time had some laughs
so like you don't want to go to the
farmer's market no i don't do you have
something against farmers markets
not really
well then why don't you want to go
because you know i
i don't feel like going with you i don't
feel like a spark
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] for what being
honest
[ __ ] you there it is it's the end of the
relationship
anyways he goes i can't even fathom why
new year's eve would be
be considered a special occasion that
would lead to her thinking that this
whole topic is ridiculous and i can't
even stand to waste time talking about
it but i wanted to hear your opinion i
think i just gave it to you my question
to you is
do you agree with that
and also do you think there are any days
on the calendar that would make a girl
think you were into her well yeah if you
took her out on valentine's day
yeah that's about it valentine's day
valentine's day that would be it
what else what other day st patrick's
day
you know you're sitting there eating a
[ __ ] meat pie next to it hammered out
of your mind with a green plastic hat on
i think he really likes me
um
the key if i could if i could do my
single life over again
is i would have been
way less fearful to be honest
you know
when relationships were starting
you know uh women are not as
psycho as you think
i mean a lot of times when you say that
women are psycho it's because you were
being deceptive
and uh yeah then they go [ __ ] psycho
yeah they definitely do but you a lot of
times create it if you just tell them
straight up front and they're like so
what is this and just be like look i'm
not looking to get in a relationship
right now
or like listen i enjoy your company but
i'm not feeling like this spark like
there's something to that next level i
just feel like you should know that and
you'd be surprised
at how well they take that
you know it's not that always you know
if you say that the second you feel it
it's usually pretty early on
so there's no really deep feelings and
that's all
people just don't want to get hurt okay
believe me i heard a lot of [ __ ]
people
believe me
and um so that's what i learned
i remember um
jesus christ years ago
when i was just a lad living in new york
i remember i hooked up with this this
woman and she was just like you know so
what is this where is this going and i
was just like uh
nowhere i'm like [ __ ]
12 i was like 35 she was 23 i'm like i'm
like 12 years older than you
you know by the time you tune 30 i'm
going to be like 60. what do you think
it's going she actually laughed
and i was just like you know
she goes so what are we doing we're just
hanging out having fun so whatever crazy
thing you want to try
but you don't want to do it with your
husband do it with me
and that was it
and she was just like all right cool
we had fun for a few weeks and then that
was [ __ ] it and nobody got hurt
and uh you know lost touch with her and
that was it
no harm no foul had a great [ __ ] time
so
there's no like but i mean look you take
them out on valentine's day and you get
them a rose
and all of that [ __ ] you start leading
them on
so what you're really talking to i feel
is you're talking to two younger guys
like me probably at that like me like
how i was i mean
how am i trying to say this you're
talking to two guys who at their age
right now i i
their skill level was what my skill
level was where they don't know how to
set it up so they're sitting there going
oh don't do this don't bring them out on
this day because that makes them think
this
um
all that says to me is that they don't
know how to communicate what's going on
so
they feel like they and they're also in
that thing where they feel like they
have to [ __ ] throw their jacket over
a mud puddle and let them walk on it in
order to get [ __ ] that night which you
don't you just have to be honest because
women enjoy sex too and they also enjoy
you telling them what the [ __ ] deal
is alright so there you go
so you don't have anything to worry
about
just don't give her a card saying i love
you
how many kids do you want i want to meet
your parents just don't do that [ __ ]
um feeling like you have to say that
[ __ ] to them all right you know what
just yeah look the fact that you you
know that those guys are full of [ __ ] i
don't need to keep going on with this
and it's already past [ __ ] two
o'clock here so i gotta get this podcast
uploaded
um that's a podcast for this week happy
new year everybody once again thank you
so much to everyone who came out to my
shows this year
it really was um
the best year of stand up i had had the
most fun on stage i got to go to the
most places perform to the all kinds of
people it was absolutely phenomenal year
for me and uh can't do it without you
guys showing up and thanks you to
everybody who writes into the podcast
listens to it and all that all right
giving thanks like it's thanksgiving but
it's [ __ ] new years all right so get
out there
pace your drinking
pick your target early close in
make her laugh
okay
take it down before 10 o'clock there you
go happy new year go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll talk to you next year